messieurs
[Musique]
bonsoir nous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle singer view on vous reçoit
dans le cadre de votre prospective votre
activité vos activités et votre prisme
de lecture vaut prisme de lecture on va
vous laisser vous présenter
succinctement on va commencer par
jacques sapir jacques sapir qui êtes
vous qu'est ce que vous faites dans la
vie qu'est ce qu'un effet je suis
professeur retraité donc j'étais
directeur d'études à l'école des hautes
études en sciences sociales économistes
bien entendu spécialiste
de la russie et des questions monétaires
internationales donc de la question de
l'euro avec quelques intérêts sur la
politique française et surtout sur le
droit constitutionnel
olivier berlioux moi
je suis actuaires donc jeu
quand j'ai créé le site les crises point
fr en 2011 que j'anime depuis lors et
qui traite d'économie de géopolitique un
peu de politique olivier delamarche je
suis économiste de marché j'ai
travaillé longtemps sur les marchés
financiers j'ai
une société qui est un family office à
genève et j'ai créé une lettre mensuelle
qu'on
peut retrouver sur un site internet qui
s'appelle au delà marche.fr alors
je vous lance les
gilet jaune
la lettre de macron l'europe la finance
les perspectives les solutions on
commence par quoi jack si
on veut on peut commencer directement
parlé chez les jaunes parce que d'une
certaine manière ils ont servi de
révélateur s'il n'y avait pas eu
justement le mouvement des gilets jaunes
nous serions très probablement en train
de nous arracher les cheveux de dire
mais tout réussi ce jeune homme je ne
dis pas ce gamin même si certains
peuvent le penser tout réussit à ce
jeune homme il a fini d'achever le droit
du travail
il a cassé largement le statut de la
sncf il aurait s'il n'y avait pas eu de
mouvement des gilets jaunes commencé sa
réforme de la sécurité sociale sa
réforme du mécanisme des retraites
peut-être même sa réforme
constitutionnelle qui ce qu'on sait
qu'il veut réduire très largement le
nombre de députés et de sénateurs donc
voilà il faut bien dire que le mouvement
des gilets jaunes ça a été non pas le
grain de sable mais le
méchant cailloux qui l'a empêché de
continuer sa marche en avant et donc oui
le mouvement des gilets jaunes il faut
absolument démarrer par ce mouvement et
puis pas seulement à cause de cette
dimension politique il ya une dimension
à la fois sociales psychologiques
émotive extrêmement importante parce que
ce mouvement a été l'occasion d'une
vague de répression policière sans
équivalent depuis ce que l'on appelait
les années marcellin de la fin des
années 60 et du début des années 70 je
n'ai jamais vu depuis ces années un tel
niveau de violence par les forces dites
de l'ordre alors c'est extrêmement
troublant parce que on pouvait penser
que la france s'était réconciliée avec
ses forces de l'ordre à la suite de
l'attentât contre charlie hebdo et
contre l'hyper cacher à la suite des
autres attentats comme l'attentât de
nice bon même chose le sacrifice du
colonel beltrame qui avait été un point
important d'ailleurs dans la dans la
mentalité générale dans la psychologie
générale et puis on voit que tout ça ça
éclate et les forces de l'ordre ont eu
un comportement extraordinairement
violent et au delà on voit qu'il y a une
espèce de durcissement de la justice une
justice qui devient extrêmement
expéditive
on a le cas dating guerre mais on a
d'autres il yad'autres gilet jaune qui
sont mis en examen qui sont convoqués
bon bref on est en train de revenir très
vite à la situation de la fin des années
60 et cela ça dit quelque chose sur
l'état de la société française une
société qui est désormais clivé de
manière irrémédiable entre une
petite élite douar allez disons 10 % de
la population qui fait sécession par
rapport au reste de la population et ça
s'est révélé de manière extrêmement crue
par le mouvement des chemises jaunes
donc oui il faut absolument démarrer par
ce mouvement des gilets jaunes oui jb
roger ribo
jacques a fait un excellent excellent
résumé un sur la problématique t1 dg les
jeunes en effet ça ça révèle plein de
choses moi ce qui me frappe le plus en
effet c'était l'apathie
depuis 1 depuis qu une vingtaine
d'années maintenant face à des réformes
régulièrement
évidemment on est au libéral est
toujours dans un sens de moins de droits
comme enjeu la quarantaine bon ben je
suis lecteur chaque année c'est tiens
qu'est-ce qu'on va enlever cette année
comme droit il y en a pratiquement pas
eu en plus on va en garder qu'un bilan
soit 25 ans qu'est-ce qu'on pourra en
plus qu'est-ce qu'a comme droit en moins
évidemment c'était insidieux cet homme
était un petit un petit truc en moins de
ci de là enfin on essaie de on commence
à dire je vous enlever beaucoup et puis
je rêve que la moitié parce qu'il ya eu
des manifestations mais par contre le
président d'après il vous fait de la
deuxième partie du travail mais s'offre
elle aussi va plus loin et c'est ce qui
se passe sans arrêt les voiles comme
rire il ya des choses qui ont prêté mm à
mâcon lamy et puis comme accros ont été
élus derrière c'est c'est encore des
encore des droits sociaux en moins et
les gens sont coincés apathique ce
qu'ils peuvent être se comprendre dans
un sens historique
qui
est que beaucoup de gens se rendre
compte qu'on a peut-être eu en termes de
droit une forme une évolution en forme
de cloche
on est passé par un maximum de droit
des années 80 à peu près et que depuis
tout le monde se rend compte qu'en
termes économiques en termes politiques
et sur plein de son plein de sujets on a
toujours une forme maintenant de
fermeture je
répète au niveau des droits au niveau la
liberté d'expression au niveau de ce que
d'humour à la télé regardez ça ce qui se
passe avec 80 aujourd'hui coluche
desproges tout ça vous oubliez ça ça
passe plus du tout alors ça semble
anecdotique mais s'est dit quelque chose
et les gens je pense aussi se disait
mais comme on est dans une optique de
qu'est-ce qu'on va m'enlever cette année
peut-être au 31 décembre tiens ça me l'a
pas pris ou c'est plutôt bien les gens
réagissaient peu manifesté peu ou alors
effectivement aller faire deux heures de
défilé entre bastille et nation avec
l'efficacité qu'on a vu dans
quoi il y avait une forme d'atonie et ce
mouvement des jeunes avec plein de
points positifs est vraiment quelques
points négatifs un bon ont secoué ont
secoué le système
politique qui en a un qui en a besoin
parce que comme le disait jacques sans
ça ils continueraient ils continueraient
parce que évidemment
on est on n'est pas dans une forme de
démocratie on est dans une forme de
monarchie élective libéral ce qui est
drôlement mieux qu'une dictature un
messi reste une monarchie élective où on
a élu et en plus cette fois ci dans des
conditions extrêmement discutable
quelqu'un qui représente peut-être 20 %
et encore du corps électoral et qui se
dit maintenant je suis élu pendant cinq
ans je fais tout ce que je veux parce
qu'en plus les institutions non
démocratique par le coup me donne une
majorité de 70% des députés
prof à ce que je veux pendant cinq ans
et comme macron en plus une
particularité qui
est un qui est assumé par lui qui était
de dire en gros moi je suis là je viens
je réforme la france voiture dans le
même sens et puis quand j'ai fini dans
son bang tour sans doute dix ans je m'en
vais c'est quelqu'un qui a toujours dit
qu'une ce proche de tes pas très
longtemps dans la politique et à partir
du moment où vous avez quelqu'un comme
ça qui vient juste d'arriver qui sait
pour lui est parti dans quelques années
on voit très bien que les manifester
tranquillement dans la rue ça ne faisait
strictement rien parce qu'il s'en fout
royalement alors qu'on voit très bien
que chirac à sarkozy ou en hollande avec
leur un défaut au bout d'un moment on
aurait dit bon réaux ça va se calmer un
peu on va partir et ça lui non enfin on
est vraiment dans une forme d'extrémisme
quand ils sont en fuite et que les
extrêmes là on a un extrême au pouvoir
un extrême néolibéralisme
d'une extrême
comment
dire un système comme ça qui n'a pas de
qui n'a pas de ressort politique il en a
fait encore ce matin un
bel exemple quand il dit finalement
rabat regarder ali et c'est facile
remettait ça changerait pas la vie d'un
seul j les jeunes nés on voit très bien
que le type laisser les faits la
politique ne connaît pas la politique
parce que la politique c'est aussi
essentiellement des symboles et quand
bien même cela changerait rien au gilet
jaune quand ya 80% des gens qui le
demande on le fait du poids final on a
besoin d'un technocrate qui s'imaginent
plus intelligent que 80% des gens c'est
il n'est pas là pour ça il est mandaté
par le peuple donc il fait ce que le
peuple veut c'est ça normalement la
démocratie après il peut évidemment
c'est très représentatif d'une dérive
élitiste
je sais pas comment comment la qualifier
de gens qui pensent qu'ils sont qui sont
plus oui il ya quelque chose de
religieux sur la partie européenne pour
le coup c'est un mois une analyse qui
est frappant on y reviendra plus tard
pour los non je pense que c'est juste
une espèce de gens qui se croient très
intelligent parce qu'ils ont fait des
nappes à ce qu'ils soient inspectés
généraux des finances qui savent très
bien ce qu'il faut faire pour le pays la
preuve on m'a confié le pays dans un
état de droit où ça en est au bout de
deux ans dans ce jeu c'est vraiment on à
la logique politique qui est éventé
pendant des mois par les médias tout en
pesant sait pas où on sera je le verse
et c'est extrêmement dangereux mais ils
se croient toujours
plus intelligent que les autres ce qui
n'est clairement pas et ça les faits
parlent tous les jours de même moins
qu'une forme d'ego boursouflé quoi c'est
ça le problème à mon avis du maquereau
levier de la marche moi
je suis d'accord avec avec jacques la
brutalité c'est la force du faible 1
et aujourd'hui
macron
c'est quoi ces c1 c'est
un pré ado qui restait prêt à dos et à
qui on donne des jouets de grands c'est
fabuleux on lui donne la carte bleue de
papa et on lui donne des jouets de
grands comment
voulez vous que ce type reste à sa place
il faut pas à pas des à des institutions
pour ankara le chef de l'état n'y a rien
l'oeil à rien parce que justement
aujourd'hui on est dans une dans une
république
où la majorité une majorité écrasante à
l'assemblée de gens qui
n'ont rien à faire là qui n'ont
absolument rien à faire là ces
dernières élections on aurait mis un
babouin à la place d'un député en face
d'un d'une dune
bref m le babouin est élu donc
il a une majorité écrasante de gens qui
n'ont rien à faire là lui non plus n'a
rien à faire là il a enfilé un costume
qui est beaucoup trop grand mais
hollande avait déjà enfilé un costume
qui était beaucoup trop grand pour lui
tous ces gens là c'était prévisible ce
qui allait se passer avec l'ailé gilet
jaune parce que à force de ne pas être
représentatifs regardez ce qui s'est
passé c'est assez caractéristique ce qui
s'est passé en essonne dans la
circonscription dans la circonscription
de valls c'est étonnant
soixante dix sept mille 500 électeurs
saaq ont bien été élu au deuxième tour
le représentant république
en marche face à une femme
de la france insoumise je sais plus son
nom enfin bref le le le gars qui a été
élue 6400
voix sur 77 mille 500 électeurs 6400
voit là la fille de la france insoumise
qui a perdu 4000 et qu'elle sait
délieront le type il va parler pour 77
1500 personnes et c'est que les
électeurs je parle pas des enfants je
parle pas des bons elle est où ceux qui
n'ont pas l'heur de leur cas il va
décider pour eux donc vous avez des gens
qui sont aujourd'hui élu avec une
minuscule partie de la population et qui
après font absolument ce qu'ils veulent
donc évidemment qu'à un moment ou à un
autre les gens vont s'en apercevoir les
gens osent dire m'attend c'est quoi
cette histoire moi j'ai pas voté pour
lui et en plus ils n'arrêtent pas de
nous nous nous taxer il arrive pas nous
parce que en fait qu'est ce qui se passe
il se passe dans en europe ce qui s'est
passé aux états unis est qu'obama on est
en train de flâner la classe moyenne
c'est terminé s'est terminée dans
quelques années il y en aura plus il en
a plu aux états unis il va plus en avoir
en europe et c'est ce que c'est le
c'était le but
2 c'était l'idée de de maquereaux et
donc parce qu'il faut bien taxés
quelqu'un ils sont dans une logique où
de toute façon il n'ya pas d'économie
ils ne feront jamais d'économies pour la
bonne et simple raison que les économies
c'est directement de vrais ceux de ce
coupé à eux s'imposer s'imposer à eux et
donc il ne ferons pas d'économie et donc
on a une logique permanente de quoi
d'endettement or l'endettement c'est
quoi c'est l'impôt futur c'est ce que
vous ne pouvez pas payer tout de suite
vous le payez plus tard c'est pour ça
qu'on sander est ce que la france vit
pas au dessus de ses moyens non
c'est pas au dessus de ses moyens c'est
au-dessus de l'aider des moyens que les
les fonctionnaires politiques
papale et pas les autres c'est que les
fonctionnaires politiques veulent se se
s'autoriser comme moyens c'est à dire
qu'ils n'ont pas envie de baisser leur
niveau de vie et ces gars là vont
continuer en permanence à imposer parce
que et parce que il crée de la dette et
donc vous le retrouvez en impôts un deux
trois quatre cinq ans plus tard mais il
n'obtient pas de il n'y a pas de miracle
si vous voulez si si vous continuez
comme ça vous êtes obligés de creuser
les déficits si vous creuser les
déficits
vous mettez de la dette si vous mettez
de la dette a forcément un moment où
faudra les payer et donc vous imposer de
plus en plus alors après vous imposer
avec des taxes vous imposer avec des
impôts peu importe mais vous imposer au
final que ce soit de la taxe ou de
l'impôt c'est la même chose jacques est
ce que les gilet jaune ne sont pas les
les
cadavres d'une mondialisation prédatrice
ils humaine est ce que c'est pas en fait
le canari dans la mine d'une
mondialisation qui est devenu
complètement psychotique et qui ne
s'arrêtera pas parce que notre corps
d'élite a été terrain formé en est
endoctriné à cette religion oui il est
très clair que les gilets jaunes
représente cette partie de la population
qui est majoritaire qui ne bénéficient
pas de la mondialisation qui souffre en
réalité de la mondialisation ça se voit
d'ailleurs sur leur structure de
consommation ce sont des gens qui
consomment moins de produits importés
que des gens qui sont beaucoup plus
fortunés se sont déjà donc par contre
certaines de leurs consommations sont
des consommations contrainte quand on ne
peut plus vivre dans une ville parce que
les loyers sont trop élevés parce que le
prix du mètre carré est trop élevé on
est obligé de partir habiter à la
campagne mais qui dit habiter à la
campagne dit aussi la nécessité de
transport pour se rendre soit son
travail soit dans d'autres lieux par
exemple amener les enfants à l'école les
amener faire du sport il ya toute une
série de raisons qui impose aux gens de
se déplacer alors si je prends mon cas à
moi j'habite dans paris j'ai pas besoin
de voiture d'ailleurs je n'ai même pas
mon permis parce que j'ai toujours eu
une offre de transports publics à ma
disposition
que ce soit le métro le rer a les bus le
tramway est amplement suffisante mais si
j'habitais à 40 ou 50 km de paris je
serais obligé d'avoir une voiture donc
ce qui veut dire que j'aurai des
dépenses contraintes à la si vous voulez
c'est bien une démonstration que il y a
un problème majeur de ce point de vue là
effectivement on peut relier cette
question à la question générale de la
mondialisation parce que c'est cette
mondialisation qui d'une part détruit
évidemment toute une série d'emplois que
l'on cherche à recréer mais que l'on ne
recrée pas évidemment sous la même forme
vous savez quand on perd un emploi
ouvriers et que l'on recrée un emploi de
service
il ya une différence de 500 à 800 euros
net de traitement sur sur sept emplois
bon et ça c'est une chose extrêmement
importante mais qui aussi si vous voulez
se
produit dans le sens où on a une
minorité de gens qui s'imaginent alors
pour certains c'est vrai toute petite
minorité pour d'autres plutôt
d'imagination qu'ils vont vivre dans un
monde complètement globalisé voilà je
vais partir passer mon week-end à
bangkok où je vais partir passer les
fêtes de noël aux états unis mais oui je
le peux regarder il y à des tarifs qui
sont tellement intéressant pour le
transport aérien et c'est bon ça c'est
en fait une minorité de gens qui sont
capables de se payer parce que pour la
majorité
eh bien on est au point de se dire mais
comment je termine le mois est une des
revendications des jeunes qui était de
venir il faudra nous nous sommes les
français qui arrivait au 15 ou au 20 du
mois pas non plus d'argent sur leur
compte et sont obligés de demander du
crédit à leurs banques en fait par un
mécanisme de de déficit sur le concours
donc ça si vous voulez c'est évident
qu'il y a un lien de ce point de vue là
entre eux la globalisation général alors
globalisation dont on peut dire qu'elle
est aujourd'hui un petit peu sur le
déclin mais dont les effets et les
effets induits sont très largement
explosifs dans la société française et
le mouvement des gels et jaune et puis
ce mouvement des gels et jaune et je
voudrais revenir là dessus bien sûr
qu'il a une dimension économique
extrêmement importante et ce qu'ils
posent la question de la justice de
l'impôt de la répartition de l'impôt et
des tasses grosso modo des prélèvements
le fait et ça c'est lié à la
mondialisation que l'on a une liberté
totale des capitaux qui empêche en
réalité de taxer les flux financiers de
taxer les grandes sociétés et ça ça
représente un manque à gagner pour
l'état qui est considérable plusieurs
estimations donnent
ce manque à gagner comme équivalent du
déficit budgétaire français ce qui
voudrait dire que c'est pas la france
qui vit au dessus de ses moyens c'est
plutôt le système de la globalisation
qui retire des moyens à la france pour
vivre comme elles le devraient et ça
dans notre lettre mois servir un peu
puis foule endettés pour
asservir un peuple il ya plusieurs
manières l'endettement d'ailleurs n'est
pas nécessairement un moyen si vous
voulez d'asservissement parce que quand
on est très endetté on
peut renverser la table rappelez-vous ce
qu'ont fait les russes en 1998 quand
même je puis dire c'est vrai mais oui
ils ont ils ont répudié ils ont répudié
la dette donc il faut jamais oublier que
cette question de la dette elle joue
dans les deux sens si vous êtes un peu
endettée la votre créancier aura
effectivement des moyens de pression
important surtout si vous êtes très
endetté si votre endettement représente
une source de revenus importante pour
votre créancier
le rapport de force s'inverse de ce
point de vue la doxa c'est un premier
point mais je voudrais revenir sur une
chose c'est que le mouvement des gilets
jaunes et ça ça a été quand même
extrêmement massif
dans le mouvement il a démarré sur une
question d'état le prix des carburants
il est passé sur la question du pouvoir
d'achat de manière très importante
et puis la déboucher sur des questions
politiques européennes
et politiques et démocratiques bien sûr
pourquoi parce que hélas il faut le dire
nous ne vivons plus sous la vème
république la vème république est morte
grosso modo des réformes qui ont été
faites de la fin des années 1980
jusqu'au début des années 2000 car si
vous lisez le texte de la vème
république
vous voyez que c'est le premier ministre
qui conduit et dirige l'action du
gouvernement le premier ministre n'a pas
à être cette espèce de factotum du
président de la république donc ça c'est
un premier point
deuxième point il y avait une
discordance voulue par les personnes
qui ont écrit de cette constitution
entre eux l'élection du président et les
élections législatives donc le problème
bien sûr c'est la question de la
proportionnelle mais malgré tout même
sens est proportionnel on avait en 1967
une assemblée où la majorité des du
pouvoir gaulliste ne tenait qu'à de
trois sièges d'ailleurs acquis dans des
circonstances a ses limites en
particulier le fameux territoire des
afars et des issas ce qui est devenu
djibouti par la suite et on sait que ça
a été l'un des sièges qui garantissait à
georges pompidou d'avoir sa majorité
donc il faut faire attention bien sûr
que la question de la proportionnelle
bien sûr que la question du référendum
sur la question extrêmement importante
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que on a
eu une déformation de
notre constitution depuis de nombreuses
années le raccourcissement du mandat du
président a joué un rôle extrêmement
important et qui a abouti à cette
situation et deuxième chose et là
effectivement c'est
la question de la qualité des femmes et
des hommes qui nous gouvernent bien sûr
le général de gaulle avait son idée de
ce qu'il fallait faire sauf qu'à un
moment donné il a posé la question aux
français est-ce que vous continuez à
suivre mon idée ou pas les français ont
dit non le général de gaulle parti
donc cela veut dire que pour le général
de gaulle le fait d'être élu ne lui
conférer pas une légitimité permanente
pendant son mandat il avait parfaitement
conscience du fait que la légitimité qui
venait de l'élection s'éroder au fil du
temps et qu'il fallait à certains
moments la refonder et c'est ça à quoi
pourrait servir par exemple le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
pour
rebondir sur ce qu'a dit jacques quand
j'aurai dit la constitution la vème
république a pris un sacré coup dans
l'aisne en 62 avec l'élection au
suffrage universel c'est ce qui torpille
la vème république passer des moments où
vous élisez le président république au
suffrage universel c'est bien entendu
lui qui a vocation à déterminer la
politique qui est faite avait vu la
force que lui donne à l'élection dans la
république comme quoi quand la city ne
l'a pas fait le général de gaulle ne l'a
pas fait il avait laissé une marge de
manoeuvre importante à georges pompidou
le corps mais dans dans sa pratique
personnelle mais le général de gaulle
était un très grand démocrate c'est lui
qui a remis la démocratie chinoise un
bon point final a appris le faire le
doble c'est unique dans l'histoire faut
pas qu'on ait une constitution qui soit
super bien quand c'est le général de
gaulle qui est au pouvoir parce que n'a
pas de bol il est à peu près une fois
par siècle donc voilà c'est
malheureusement faut attendre un peu
donc mené une institution qui soit fait
pour limiter justement les pouvoirs et
quand on voit comment il fait la
protection assez normal que il se forme
de dérive et qui aboutisse à quelque
chose d'assez logique aujourd'hui et
c'est vrai que la logique ultime c'est
d'enlever le poste de poing minus qui
sert à peu près rien après on peut
réfléchir à d'autres évolutions bien sûr
mais en tout cas sur cet axe là la vème
république c'est
son cas c'est la façon dont je vois les
choses mais j'ai trouvé intéressant
c'est de voir que après un démarrage de
revendications des jeunes qui sont
partis un peu dans tous les sens au bout
d'un moment au bout de deux trois
semaines ça
quand je commence à regarder tient ferme
et qu'est ce qu'ils veulent en plus que
l'histoire des taxes qui héritait
effectivement la
goutte de gasoil qui a mis le feu aux
poudres mais le
l'ensemble des revendications partait un
peu dans tous les sens et c'était
contradictoires des gens disaient
vêtements je paie trop d'impôts je
comprends bien par contre ce qui est
plus de services publics aillent au bout
d'un moment ça devient compliqué mais
c'est un gros aprilia une 3e étape où
les gens ont compris que le truc
vraiment important c'était le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne parce que c'était
un des points qui leur permettraient
d'avoir plein d'autres choses que le
système politique et les représentants
aujourd'hui ne leur ne leur donnerai pas
elle s'allonge au bout c'est un combat
personnel que j'ai depuis très longtemps
depuis dizaine d'années j'ai fait une
pétition il ya deux ans sur un bras il
nous faut vraiment référendum
d'initiative citoyenne parce que je
pense que c'est le combat du 21e siècle
en tout cas au moins de la première
partie du 21e siècle pour mettre
en adéquation les pratiques politiques
avec un point qui est très important qui
est l'élévation du niveau on
va dire éducatif et un peu
d'informations quand c'est pas trop
déformé de la population on est plus en
1850 avec un immense partie de la
population qui n'a pas accès à
l'éducation ou à l'information et
forcément ça doit changer un certain
nombre de choses et on ne peut pas
garder des pratiques qui n'évolue pas
depuis un siècle et demi et le
référendum citoyen est très important
parce qu'il ya plein de questions qui
font que l'ensemble des citoyens peut
vraiment s'en saisir en discuter on l'a
vu en 2005 au moment du référendum
c'était quand même très étonnant de voir
la population qui tout d'un coup c'est
vraiment intéressé d'assez près un truc
qui était un bout fable qui était
gigantesque qui était compliquée et on
voit que les gens comme en fait cet
effort là et c'était un bon nombre d
constitutionnel de 2005 un peu en 92
mais je pense que l'absence d'internet
en fait à jouer un changement sur
internet en 92 et ne passait pas à
masquer ce me semble assez évident parce
que les quelques poids aurait évidemment
bascule est plus d'informations avec des
balles et et 1005 sa bascule à ce moment
là c'est d'ailleurs à ce moment là que
les gens commencent à se rendre compte
que bon faut faire attention falloir
arrêter les référendum faut arrêter de
demander l'avis aux gens et donc
renforce l'aspect monarchique en tout
cas non démocratique du système actuel
et ce avec ce combat du fnlc citoyenne
est à mon sens extrêmement important on
doit vraiment être discuté débattu et
c'est assez largement pour ceux que ça
intéresse depuis la semaine dernière
j'ai lancer un débat participatif sur
mon site les crises point fr pour
rédiger un
référendum cette île située à peu se
rédiger de différentes façons et moi
j'en propose une assez originale avec
qui me semble quand même assez
importante si on veut pas se faire
truander en tout cas conteste ça qui
donne pas mettre un seuil de signature
tout le monde parle de ça comme d'une
évidence sauf que personne ne sait quel
seuil faut mettre et qu'évidemment le
but va être de mettre le sait le plus
haut possible au cannet à peu près
jamais mais moi je pense que ce serait
intéressant même de discuter de tester
un système contraire qui serait tout
simplement qu'un dimanche par an on vote
sur cette question avec toujours cette
et que les gens votent et je pense par
un système sur
internet comme on le fait pour les pour
les impôts 1 pour une machine un système
comme ça pour aller voter et soutenir un
certain nombre de questions et vous
regardez la fin de l'année en gros vous
prenez les sept qui en plus de
signatures et voulait passer à
référendum ce qui permet de ne pas axer
sur une seule question d'être sur cannes
à ses parents n'étaient pas se retrouver
non plus avec un système contraire pour
y avoir 200 affaires acquis et empirait
lerrick olivier delamarche serait ce
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
est-ce que c'est pas un barnum pour
éteindre le feu est ce que le référendum
que la consultation populaire que macro
est en train d'organiser est-ce que
c'est pas un effet de manche pour mais
c'est différent du du référendum
d'initiative citoyenne leleu enfin
j'veux dire on n'a pas faut pas
réinventer la poudre le fil à couper le
beurre les suisses se font très bien
depuis des années et des années ça
marche très bien alors évidemment à les
imbéciles de 2,2
député en marche ont fait exploser ont
fait une levée de boucliers en disant
toute façon c'est pour voter pour la
couleur des toilettes dans les mairies
non c'est pas vrai ils votent sur sur
des problèmes budgétaires ils votent sur
des sur sûr là il va y avoir une
votation bientôt sur sur l'impôt sur les
sociétés pour l'harmoniser dans toute la
suisse donc le dire ils votent sur des
choses qui sont qui sont autres que avec
des tic et ça marche très bien et j'ai
pas l'impression que les suisses soit
dans une dictature ça marche ça marche
formidablement bien et c'est pas ça le
pays marche bien un pas bon donc on
aimerait bien marché comme d'ailleurs
donc
voilà fayat il y a
il faut il faut arrêter là dessus le la
consultation de macron
c'est
juste de la com c'est de la com depuis
passé de la com depuis depuis très
longtemps c'est ce qu'il faut quand même
voir il faut il faut là dessus je pense
on a parlé de la mondialisation on a
parlé de
la dérive des institutions mais la
dérive des institutions et le fait que
les gens se révoltent aussi
lyon va y retomber mais est dû à
l'europe je veux dire on a aujourd'hui
c'est quoi le pouvoir de monsieur macron
d'où viennent la moitié des choses qu'il
a fait passer la loi sur le travail et
c'est un bien de l'europe bon donc ça
vient de l'europe où je vous rappelle
qu'il ya quand même un alcoolique
notoire qui s'appelle monsieur juncker
qui a des sciatiques à partir de 14
heures et qui dirige l'europe alors que
c'est un type qui n'est pas élu donc
qu'on ne peut pas virer corse qui est le
point le plus anti démocratique possible
quand donc il ya près de 100 boer donc
il n'y a pas de vote donc on ne peut pas
le sortir et c'est lui qui décide pour
nous donc évidemment qu'au bout d'un
moment les gens en ont marre déjà les
nôtres ne sont pas représentatifs
puisque il ya ils sont élus avec 15% ou
20% de la population à peine et mais
en plus de ça vous les elysées et c'est
pas eux qui font qu'ils font les lois ça
se passe en europe avec des gens qui ne
sont pas élus il
ya on est arrivé à un point où ça
devient une blague quand vous avez des
gens qui prennent des décisions comme en
grèce comme comme en 2005 et c'est à
vous avez là dessus les l'europe qui dit
ah oui ils vont mais bon vous avez mal
voter les gab il va falloir recommencer
bon on est on donne un nom c'est ce
qu'on peut être que ce qui se passera en
mode mais peuvent faire sur la grande
bretagne pour l'instant c'est un peu
c'est un peu trop frais pour je
pense que ça sera pour nous on se dirige
plutôt vers un break site qu'autre chose
mais bon après c'est autre chose mais on
est on est dans quelque chose ou on vous
empêche de sortir alors que paraît-il
c'est une grande communauté de copains
d'amis et depuis quand on vous empêche
de sortir d'un groupe d'amis est quelque
chose qui va pas
donc c'est
aussi la rentrée laissez les sortir là
donc on vous pompe votre pognon quand
vous êtes deux et on vous empêche de
sentir ces secteurs c'est pas autre
chose donc et le
avec juncker comme grand gourou de la
secte
donc il ya quelque chose qu'il ya
quelque chose qui évidemment à un moment
peser tellement sûr sur les sept classes
moyennes qui ont plein la gueule passez
moi l'expression
depuis un moment que fallait que ça
sorte et c'est en train de sortir alors
c'est vrai que c'est sorti au départ
avec des idées dans tous les sens parce
que c'est justement pas un mouvement qui
est structuré les politiques avaient
l'habitude d'avoir un syndicat devons ou
une corporation de vente devant eux là
aujourd'hui c'est pas une corporation
c'est c'est la classe moyenne qui tout
d'un coup c'est dit il en a marre qu'on
nous prenne pour des pour des imbéciles
donc ils sont retrouvés sur des ronds
points et ils ont ils ont essayé plus ou
moins de structurer leur truc mais c'est
qu'on voit bien que c'est compliqué il
ya des batailles d'ego maintenant entre
certains représentants et c'est pourquoi
parce que finalement il n'y a pas de
représentant et finalement il doit à la
limite il doit pas y en avoir deux
représentants sais c'est le peuple qui
se réveille et puis qui se dit à un
moment mais ça
suffit coiffa on est on est dans quelque
chose qui est absolument
antidémocratique
on nous dit non vous ne pouvez pas
sortir vous ne pouvez pas faire si vous
ne pouvez pas faire ça si vous le faites
pour voir voter si vous faites on va
passer au dessus de vous on va demander
aux députés de voter autrement enfin on
est dans quelque chose qui est
on a l'impression qu'on compte qu'on en
finit pas de tomber l'euro
l'euro c'est une religion est ce que
c'est quand
vous critiquez le roux est ce que vous
êtes taxé de être
contre les libertés contre 8 ou 5 e vous
êtes un monstre mais très clairement
l'euro alors il ya deux choses
différentes à une question de l'union
européenne et puis à la question de
l'euro l'euro c'est très nettement une
question religieuse à partir du moment
où vous attaquer l'angle d'attaqué à
l'euro avec des arguments construit
d'ailleurs mes arguments ne sont pas
très différents des arguments d'autres
économistes qui sont aussi contre
l'europe a que des français pas mal
d'économistes anglo saxons qui sont
contre l'euro et même je dois le dire
des économistes qui sont pour l'euro
parce qu'il y à beaucoup d'économistes
maintenant mon quasi homonyme andré
sapir en fait partie
qu'ils disent oui on est tout à fait
d'accord l'euro actuel ne fonctionne pas
les conditions nécessaires pour qu'il
fonctionne ne sont pas réunies mais mais
mais mais mais il faut se battre pour
que ces conditions soient un jour réunis
et c'est là évidemment ou en hiver et d
si on l'a pas fait depuis vingt ans ne
le fera pas dans les cinq années qui
viennent c'est très clair et par
ailleurs il faut regarder qu'est ce que
ça voudrait dire d'avoir des des
conditions pour qu'un euro fonctionne et
on sait que cela imposerait en fait de
prélever massivement de la richesse sur
l'allemagne entre 8 et 12% du pib par an
en fait ça dépend de la manière dont on
fait les calculs et on voit très bien
que c'est ma part la question que les
allemands ne veulent pas ou ne peuvent
pas peuvent pas s'ils voulaient et ça
n'a pas de sens de demander quelque
chose un pays qui ne peut pas le faire
donc voilà mais il fait quand même un
clavier avec soin avec la grèce ils ont
demandé des choses qui était
pratiquement impossible oui mais même
ceux qui étaient demandés à la grèce et
d'un niveau inférieur on a demandé à la
grèce des prélèvements de l'ordre de 4 à
5 % du pib par an alors ce qui était
dramatique compte tenu de la situation
de la grèce mais ça reste encore très
inférieur à ce qu'il faudrait demander à
l'allemagne
de payer s'ils voulaient c'est là
justement tout le paradoxe de l'euro
donc oui la question de l'euro et pour
les défenseurs de l'euro à l'évidence
une question dans votre lit c'est
l'allemagne ou l'italie qui veut sortir
en premier alors
je
vais je vais pas tirer de plans sur la
comète l'allemagne n'a aucun intérêt à
sortir de l'euro actuellement parce que
l'euro si vous voulez est sous-évalué
par rapport à ce que serait le
deutschmark c'est le deutschmark
existait on voit très bien que si le
deutschmark exister il se situerait
grosso modo à avec un taux de change de
l'ordre de 1 $ 35 $ 45 on est
actuellement autour de 1 $ 14 dollars
14,1 $ can donc vous imaginez
immédiatement tout le gain que cela
porte à l'économie allemand dont non
l'allemagne ne sortira pas dans la
région il ya quand même quelque chose là
dessus c'est que l'allemagne va aussi à
un moment faire le calcul parce que sa
voix de ce que ça lui coûterait si
quelqu'un l'a sortait de l'euro c'est à
dire si si l'italie se prépare imaginons
que l'italie se prépare et imaginons
qu'italie sorte à ce moment là
l'allemagne elle va faire un gros chèque
parce que ces banques vont tomber parce
que là elle a beaucoup d'italiennes dans
l'est et donc après c1 c'est un rapport
de deux gains de gains pertes est ce que
aujourd'hui
s'organiser pour sortir de l'euro et le
faire de façon organisée
et avoir derrière un euro qui
remonterait à 1 40 ne serait pas moins
douloureux que de subir la sortie de
l'euro parce que c'est ça qui va se
passer si l'italie sort par exemple et
de subir la sortie de l'euro et à ce
moment là de ne pas la contrôler et et
d'avoir des pertes probablement
monumentale et je pense qu'ils sont en
train de faire le calcul est ce que si
le calcul est positif pour eux ils
n'hésiteront pas une seconde si le
calcul est un peu négatif peut-être
qu'ils attendent on va encore devoir
d'abord je ne pense pas que sur cette
question là on soit dans le domaine de
la rationalité jeu s'annonce
à on est donc voilà on a ça c'est après
mois après il faut bien comprendre une
chose si l'italie sort de l'euro l'euro
explose toutes les manières parce que
quand la couleur quand on connaît la
nature des spécialisations industrielle
de l'économie italienne et de l'économie
française on voit que en réalité la
france et l'italie sont en situation de
concurrence relative importante
admettons que l'italie sorte de l'euro
et voit sa monnaie se déprécier 2 1% par
rapport aux cours de l'euro le choc
induits sur l'économie française serait
tellement dramatique que cela
contraindrait n'importe quel
gouvernement français à sortir aussi
l'euro et il faut bien dire que sans
l'italie et sans la france l'euro
n'existe plus ce qui existe à la limite
c'est une zone mark étendue c'est une
zone marques incluant l'autriche les
pays-bas bon mais ce n'est plus ce n'est
plus l'euro donc là je crois que on est
très claire sur cette question
maintenant il ya un autre problème est
qu'il faut toujours distinguer de l'euro
parce que il ya des pays de l'union
européenne qui n'ont pas l'euro par
exemple la suède jusqu'au
29 mars de cette année encore la
grande-bretagne bon
c'est
la question justement des
réglementations de l'union européenne et
du mode de fonctionnement de l'union
européenne et là on voit que l'on a
transféré sans le dire une grosse partie
de la souveraineté des états membres à
la commission européenne une commission
qui est normalement désigné
par les gouvernements donc
on dit ah oui mais vous voyez c'est
quand même du démocratique bien sûr
c'est du democratic indirects cdu
démocratique à deux tours à trois tours
mais sa raison pratique non en réalité
on a là un groupe de technocrates qui
travaillent de manière largement séparés
de ce qui se passe dans les
gouvernements et c'était un des
problèmes qui étaient posées en italie
je suis allé en italie à
la fin de l'année 2018 et j'ai pu
discuter avec toute une série
d'économies ce italien il disait mais le
problème s'ils voulaient qui a le droit
de nous dire le niveau de déficit est ce
que le vote du budget est un attribut de
la souveraineté du peuple italien ou
est-ce que ça ne l'est pas voulait donc
on voit bien que c'est la question de la
souveraineté qui est posée de manière
centrale à travers le fonctionnement des
institutions de l'union européenne
voulait rebondir au dessus
oui il ya plein de choses à dire
je partage l'analyse l'analyse de
jacques ont peut-être pour compléter
quelques points comme ça moi je dirais
qu'il faut pas oublier que l'euro c'est
pas une monnaie c'est un instrument de
domination politique et ça on l'a vu en
grèce ont fermé les autres la mode de
gouvernance c'est un outil qui est fait
pour que justement il moins en moins
démocratie évidemment après euros est
venu un contrôle des politiques
économiques puis un contrôle des budgets
et un contrôle doit peu près tout ce qui
se fait dans un exemple la le
prélèvement à la source c'était une
demande du conseil européen quand même
bien faire l'impôt à la source en france
on est arrivé à un niveau de
pertes démocratique qui est colossal qui
explique sans doute aussi une perte de
qualité du personnel politique parce
qu'on ait fait voter ministre ça sert à
rien ça sert à les tweets et mais pas
plus que ça et c'est d'ailleurs quand on
voit le niveau des gares des niveaux des
ministres et plein de choses qu'on peut
plus faire la rigueur vous pouvez
détricoter un peu droit social encore
plus mais c'est s'est joué à neyron
kouassi détruire encore plus mais c'est
sûrement pas de faire prenez 81 mais à
quand le gouvernement arrive en prêt
pour peut être contre j'ai pas tout si
ça peut être une bonne mauvaise idée
l'établissent tiens on va nationaliser
toutes les banques et toutes les
assurances taisez
vous mais c'est peut-être une mauvaise
idée mais ils le font aujourd'hui
vous imaginez que le truc il est un
horizon mais un faisable fermement 2012
en pipe autant hollande
a dit oui je vais peut-être juste coupé
un tout petit peu les bords qu'ils ont
rien fait c'est même pas on est à un
niveau de perte du pouvoir qui est
colossal et en effet vous êtes un type
talentueux mais vous allez faire ni
politique ni directeur de cabinet ces
personnes avaient des benalla au final
enfin quand vous êtes des qualités vous
n'allez plus là dedans parce que mes
faut discuter des gens comme ça c'est
déjà très difficile parce qu'en plus ils
essayent de faire des économies sans
arrêt sur les sur
les conseillers ministériels ce qui là
encore il faut au contraire elle
n'entendait plus un peu leur disant vous
faites des économies mais il me faut
c'est le cerveau de l'état et hollande
comme ma chronique montrer qu'ils en
arrivent à venir va diminuer le cerveau
super 16 mois c'est réussi mais bon vous
d'économiser ai-je pas combien dépense
et bien plus donc si je reviens sur
l'aspect 1 sur l'aspect un
démocratiquement voit très bien qu'il ya
une évaporation et ça c'est un point qui
est très important donc évidemment quand
vous votez pour ça que les gens y votent
ou changer de président en charge et
même de partis puis passe rien mais se
passe rien c'est normal parce que toutes
les politiques économiques qui sont
comme un rôle central en politique sont
déjà pré déterminées cd injonction au
niveau européen donc l'euro c'est une
des fonctions de l'euro en plus de la
deuxième fonction dont on a parlé qu'une
fonction un peu aux religieuses puisqu
ils ont une espèce de vision de
construction d'un super état européen et
l'âge insiste j'ai les types qui sont
sans arrêt en train de critiquer jacques
mois d or et vous êtes je sais pas quoi
des des demandes des souverainistes sa
souveraineté sera déviée sur la
démocratie c'était pas souverain et moi
je vois est souverain dans la vie je
vais décider je veux pas qu'on décide
pour moi donc il ya cet aspect là mais
c'est rigolo et l'équipe quelle est leur
projet mais il est clair ils veulent
construire une nation mais
qu'est ce qui est plus nationaliste que
des types qui veulent construire une
nation et en plus qui n'existe pas qui
n'a jamais existé dans les peuples ne
veulent pas tiens c'est quand même du
top nationaliste à ce niveau là les
types vous êtes puisque en plus un dépôt
mes trucs qu'on va faire ce serait bien
c'est de faire une arme et il faut faire
une armée attention
moi donc tu veux qu'on soit une nation
en objective-c faire une armée parce
qu'il ya plein d'ennemis autour c'est
sympa et ça ils arrivent quand même par
un renversement à les critiquer les
hawks ont juste démocrate de base même
si l'on vous disait le système fiscal il
veut et on veut plein de choses si oui
ça perd on voit très bien enfin vous
regardez en 80 ans qu'ils ont fait puis
vous calculez le nombre de millénaire
pour arriver à une harmonisation et
diront ils ont fait un système il ya des
fraudeurs chez nous c'est à dire que
l'irlande c'est à dire que les pays bas
en partie la belgique le luxembourg
ils ont un business model en partie
d'aller essayer de piquer l'argent aux
collègues c'est à dire si marion nous et
ce que je fais je commence par te
tromper je lui ça va bien se passer on
va construire des choses super solide
c'est extraordinaire et comme parfois la
commission essaie de faire des choses
ils ont arrivés un certain nombre de cas
de condamnés l'irlande ou les pays-bas
pour les obliger à aller réclamer de
l'argent à google ou aux gars femme
parce que il avait fait des choses
illégales pour les attirer c'est à dire
que la loi leur dit c'est bon les gars
vous pouvez vous avez gagné finalement
demandé tant de milliards à google le
gouvernement fait non fait on va pas on
va pas le faire il faut que ce soit la
commission qu'il en fasse un procès en
disant vous puis-je aller réclamer
l'argent de vous avez droit à google
lorsqu'un ce niveau de corruption de ces
types là et s'est dit prêt à mener celui
que oui non c'est l'europe ça va bien se
passer on va construire quelque chose en
commun donc en fait on un nationalisme
débridé d'où l'aspect dont on parle un
peu religieux s'étudie nippert
nationaliste canton quand on a regardé
et surtout qui se fait avec des peuples
qui n'en veulent pas problème
supplémentaire comme évidemment ces gens
ne sont pas des démocrates et sapho
vraiment le marteler ces gens ne sont
pas démocrates ils
ont commencé à le faire et l'euro c'est
un pas majeur dans la fédéralisation
dans la construction de cet état et et
ça c'est quelque chose que que les gens
ont pas bien vu on pas bien compris
parce que c est un peu complexe en fait
pour un ensemble politique de son
ensemble de capacités politiques on en a
déjà passé une grosse partie à l'échelon
supérieur qui n'est pas contrôlée qui
n'est pas démocratique pourquoi qu'il ya
extrêmement peu et donc c'est pour ça
que en fait quand on vote ça change pas
grand chose c'est pour ça que parfois
dans des élans de lucidité de franchise
vous pouvez voir un grand coeur qui dit
mais votre vote ne va rien changer on
peut pas voter contre et traités
européens beaucoup de gens sur ce témoin
au 6 mai mais posons-nous de seconde il
est honnête juncker quelle est sa vision
c'est la vision d'un fédéralisme qui
voit que la moitié du boulot est fait et
c'est comme en france vous vous dites
que maintient quant à la présidentielle
ce cas voter l'alsace on s'en fout un
peu serré surtout c'est la beauté dans
le sens contraire de toutes les autres
régions donc le vote en alsace ne change
pas la politique en france le vote
aujourd'hui pour eux en france ou en
grèce ou en espagne ne change pas la
politique européenne et quelque part on
peut pas leur enlever ça c'est
puisqu'ils sont dans une logique
fédérale enfin je dis attendez on n'est
pas d'accord pour avoir une logique
fédérale après si on est d'accord bah
oui on comprend votre logique et on voit
que cette étape-là se poursuit et se
poursuit d'ailleurs en ce moment même
puisque j'ai publié tout à l'heure le le
projet de du traité d'aix la chapelle
qui va être signé entre merkel et et
macron la semaine prochaine il ya plein
de fantasmes délirants autour de ça mais
quand vous voyez les tipis sont en train
de nous refaire un projet de mini union
européenne on n'était pas au courant et
on apprend ça pour la semaine prochaine
c'est une première étape quand vous
regardez les objectifs ça commence à
être très clair oui il ya plein de
politique pour faire quand même demande
essayer de coordonner avec les allemands
pour voir quand on veut faire quelque
chose s'ils sont calmes et sont d'accord
pour essayer de mettre du bilinguisme
dans plein de régions de traiter les
régions frontalières pas de la même
façon que les autres régions enfin moi
ça regardez bien vous allez on va se
poser pour marseille est d'accord les
mecs ne parle pas on parle d'en débattre
et d'afrique va j'ai ramé un petit
moment pour trouver pour trouver le
protocole waura
les liens vous voyez c'est pas alors
c'est pas aussi scandaleux que ce qu'on
dit mais c'est une étape de plus encore
on s'y met ça sert à quoi et puis sans
germanophobie pourquoi avec l'allemagne
pour papa de l'espagne et l'italie monde
paie plus sympa faire des choses avec
avec les espagnols en ce moment donc
c'est un conseil des ministres franco
allemand qui existe depuis un petit
moment mais qui encore cette fois gravé
dans le marbre c'est un ministre
allemand tous les trois mois qui va
venir au conseil des ministres français
bon j'espère qu'à patrick trop
confidentielle à ce moment là est un des
puits vous vous dites mais les autres
pays comment ils vont prendre ça on a
quoi on est en train de faire un blog
gigantesque entre la france et
l'allemagne et puis on va dire bon aux
italiens bon vous ferez ce qu'on va vous
enfin déjà dans la course ou sans leurs
projets ont votre mec sommes incapables
de le mener à terme parce qu'ils n'ont
pas de sens politique parce que ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure c'est une
incapacité à gérer les différences et à
construire de façon raisonnable un
projet en commun c'est toujours une
forme violente je
peux conduire un mot d'ailleurs ces
violences policières tout à leur met une
violence aussi dans le politique qui est
quand même assez stupéfiante question
d'internet pourquoi serait-il gênant
qu'il y ait une nation européenne avec
lili formalisé hasard uniformisation
législatives
et surtout le fiscalité d'abord
il faut dire une nation c'est un peuple
et inversement un peuple c'est une
nation tu as aussi dès jeudi à un peuple
un peuple la culture on va on va y venir
parce que qu'est-ce qui fait peuple
quelle est la différence entre eux une
masse de population qui est un concept
démographique est un concept politique
qui s'appelle le peuple et c'est le fait
que le peuple est réunie autour de sa
culture politique et il faut constater
qu'aujourd'hui la culture politique
française est spécifique par rapport à
la culture politique italienne qui elle
même est spécifique par rapport à la
culture politique allemande qu'elle même
et spécifique par rapport à la culture
politique britannique non pas qu'il n'y
ait pas des points communs entre ces
différentes cultures politiques mais
nous avons un rapport différent au
pouvoir central au pouce des régions au
pouvoir du président les allemands par
exemple ne veulent pas avoir de
président tout se joue autour du premier
ministre qui s'appelle le chancelier ou
la chancelière s'est donc on est bien
sûr une logique de politique et une
logique d'institutions politiques dire
que l'on veut construire une europe
fédérale supposerait que en amont nous
ayons déjà eu une uniformisation de la
culture politique et ça ça
ne peut pas se faire alors je ne dis pas
que ça ne se fera pas dans 200 300 400
ans je n'en sais rien après tout la
culture politique sur
le territoire que l'on appelle la france
la culture politique entre les régions
de vieilles occupation romaine grosso
modo les
régions du midi et les régions du nord
de la seine la culture politique était
très différente et cette culture
politique
au bout de quelques siècles un nc
finalement homogénéiser simplement ce
qu'il faut toujours rappeler c'est que
dans cette construction qui est une
construction jointe commune du peuple et
de la nation il ya des événements
importants qui permettent de vérifier
cela alors en france dit toujours oui la
bataille de bouvines qui était un point
essentiel dans la construction de la
nation française il y à jeanne d'arc et
jeanne d'arc montre l'existence d'un
patriotisme français qui
d'une certaine manière est supérieur aux
règles lignage hier qui déterminait qui
devait être le roi et qui ne pouvaient
pas l'être c'est donc on voit bien il ya
ça on le voit aussi après soit henri iv
quand il y a cette espèce de soulèvement
populaire contre les espagnols qui va
d'une certaine manière permettre de
refaire l'unification entre les
catholiques et les protestants
c'est le fameux mot qui écrit henri iv
après la bataille de fontaine française
pantois
brave biron nous avons battu les
espagnols à fontaine française est tu
n'y étais pas puis qui at il battu les
espagnols avec des troupes protestantes
mais il le dit un autre protection qui
n'avait pas voulu donc il ya des moments
où il faut faire silence sur ce qui peut
nous diviser pour ne prendre que ce qui
peut nous unir bref et puis évidemment
il ya la révolution française donc on le
voit la construction d'un peuple et la
construction d'une nation ça prend des
siècles et parfois il ya des pays où ça
se passe relativement mal prenons
le cas de l'italie dans le lit tally
encore aujourd'hui ou de la belgique
bien sûr bon mais dans le cas de
l'italie on voit très bien que le
mécanisme de l'unité italienne a été en
fait une forme de colonisation de
l'italie centrale et méridionale pas
l'italie du nord ce qu'il laisse encore
des traces et on le voit au niveau
électoral avec le fait que les
deux parties qui sont toujours de
pouvoir le movimento est elle est là les
gars sont majoritaires mais dans des
régions différentes de s'inquiéter les
ligueurs voilà la ligue est plutôt
majoritaire au nord et le mouvement 5
étoiles est plutôt majoritaire au sud
est ce qu'on peut qualifier ça oui c'est
en train de changer mais oui mais au
départ il y avait encore sa bombe donc
on voit très bien que
la
constitution d'une nation c'est un
processus très long et j'ai un collègue
italien qui dit en fait nous italiens
nous avons déjà vécu l'histoire de la
monnaie unique c'est le moment où la
lyre piémontaise s'est imposée comme la
monnaie de l'italie réunifiée parce que
ça ça détruit l'économie du sud et c'est
vrai quand vous regardez l'économie du
royaume de naples vous voyez que cette
économie
elle était pas florissante mais elle
n'était pas si différente de l'économie
du piémont et à partir du moment où ce
fait l'unité italienne et où se fait
l'unité monétaire de l'italie est bien
le sud rentrant crise est une crise dont
il n'est pas encore complètement sortis
olivier delamarche ensuite olivier burri
moi
je pense que le là
aujourd'hui font franchement sur sur
l'euro qui
n'est pas d'accord à part à parler les
les responsables de la commission
européenne à mai mais à peu près tous
les économistes le le dise même
d'ailleurs les économistes qui étaient
anciennement pour le roux sont venus sur
sur ses positions la donc maintenant
c'est une question de temps
quand tu n'es pas là parce qu'elle est
vraiment importante et je te rendrai
parole faut pas garder les économistes
et bien c'est comme les médecins 51
cancer du poumon tuera l'opt homologue
et à la vie du dentiste et du podologue
et intéresse pas hoca faut regarder
l'avis des économistes spécialistes de
la monnaie oui sont pas nombreux j'ai
d'économistes qui sont des ultralibéraux
qu treuil pour les banques quand vous
regardez les universitaires qui
travaille sur la monnaie l'immense
majorité depuis le début contre le ou
non mais on est dedans mais il faut le
rappeler c'est à dire que l'âge est très
difficile a dit jamais sérieux et pour
lorsque tout le monde tous les gens
sérieux sont sont contre l'euro disent
que c'est quelque chose qui ne marche
pas et puis on a aujourd'hui on a des on
a des faits on a des chiffres on sait
que ça ne fonctionne pas donc et on voit
que lorsqu'on
on parle avec des des européistes on va
dire on va appeler ça comme ça on
va quand on parle avec des européistes
quel est l'argument qu'ils ont
l'argument qu'ils ont aujourd'hui c'est
quand même assez faible c'est dire mais
si on sort ça va être épouvantable c'est
pas un argument c'est pas factuel on ne
parle pas de ce qui s'est passé on ne
parle pas d'eux des chiffres on vous dit
si on sort c'est épouvantable donc c'est
c'est comme si dans
une entreprise ou dans la vie on fait on
fait quelque chose ça ne fonctionne pas
et on dit ah ben non on va continuer
quand même c'est du jamais vu
intellectuellement studio on peut pas
dire autre chose donc le moi je pense
que le problème va se régler et va se
régler d'autant plus rapidement que moi
je suis assez persuadé qu' on est
aujourd'hui en récession en europe on
est en récession en chine on est en
récession très probablement siens un
jour on l'a quitté d'ailleurs la
récession parce que depuis 2008 moi je
suis pas bien sûr qu'on l'ait quitté
m'enfin bon on est en récession aussi
sur sur le continent américain et donc
ce que je me dis c'est que ça va être
compliqué avec une récession mondiale
avec pour cette pour ce coup là aucune
région qui sera réellement en croissance
c'est c'est assez nouveau parce qu'en
général il y avait quand même toujours
une région qui sont tirés à peu près et
qui finalement tiré qui tiraient les
autres
là on va être en récession tous en même
temps et on y est déjà alors que ce qui
m'amuse c'est de voir des gens qui sont
en train de dire oui on sera peut-être
en récession à la fin de l'année et que
ça non on y est déjà quand on regarde
les
indicateurs les indicateurs ils sont
tous en train de passer on sait que pour
l'achat est censé augmenter de 1.5
il est censé comme tous les débuts
d'année on est censé faire deux et demi
pour cent de croissance on est censé
avoir une baisse du chômage on est censé
avoir des rémunérations
qui augmentent enfin on est toujours
censé sauf qu'à la fin de l'année on
s'aperçoit que ce n'était pas ça bon
donc en 2018 je vous rappel en début
d'année 2018 on était censé avoir la
liste l'alignement des astres c'est à
dire une croissance extraordinaire des
résultats de sociétés extraordinaire et
une bourse extraordinaire et tout allait
bien d'accord on était parti pour avoir
du quatre et demi pour cent de
croissance aux états unis ce qui ne sera
pas une
baisse des dettes partout une baisse des
déficits budgétaires et serpents c'est
pas ce qui s'est passé et c'est habituel
je dirais tous les débuts de l'année on
vous annonce des choses extraordinaires
et puis on s'aperçoit au fur et à mesure
de l'année qui s'écoule que c'est pas
vraiment ça bon donc là aujourd'hui on a
des indicateurs moi je regarde et on a
des par exemple aux états unis vous
retrouver depuis déjà trois ou quatre
mois avec des rentrées fiscales pour les
entreprises qui sont plus faibles on n'a
jamais vu de baisse des rentrées
fiscales taux égal de baisse des
rentrées fiscales sent qu'il ya une
récession dans les trois mois qui sut
c'est un fait personne ne va regarder
cet indicateur parce que c'est bien trop
fatigant mais il se trouve que c'est ça
on sait qu'il ya un ralentissement qui
est fort en chine et on peut le le
corroborer il suffit d'aller regarder
quelques indicateurs de fret de
l'électricité etc et donc on sait que la
chine est en train de ralentir est en
train de ralentir fortement on sait
qu'en europe l'italie des gens aisés
ions la france
on en est on y est aussi très
probablement l'allemagne est en train de
ralentir fortement et c'est donc tout ça
fait que on va se retrouver cette année
où on était encore il ya quelques
semaines en train de taper sur les
italiens parce que il avait sorti un
déficit
budgétaire de 2 ou 2 4 et que c'était
catastrophique alors que pendant ce
temps là nous on était à 2 8 mais le
problème et est même pas là moi je vous
annonce ce qui va se passer on va être à
4% déficit budgétaire à la fin de
l'année pourquoi parce qu'il y aura
moins de rentrées s'il ya une récession
il y aura nettement moins de rentrée et
vous serez à quatre en italie vous serez
à quatre ou à cinq ans en france et est
donc là on va se poser des vraies
questions la
vraie question ça va être que ça va être
compliqué d'aller taper sur l'italie en
leur disant c'est pas bien ce que vous
faites est donc on va avoir moi je peux
je pense que le tout jeu aujourd'hui
italien c'est le jeu de salvini puisque
finalement le vrai premier ministre sait
qui c'est lui enfin je parle sous ton
contrôle mais priori c'est quand même le
type le plus en vue plus en vue c'est le
type le plus en vue aujourd'hui et je
pense que moi de gg quand même
l'impression qu'il est en train de de
nous faire le coup du magicien c'est à
dire que on fixe l'attention des gens
sur le sur le la migration on fixe
l'attention des gens sur le bateau qu'on
refuse extra alors évidemment tout le
monde y va parce que c'est le sait le
grand truc et tout le monde se précipite
là dessus en traitant de sale eau etc
non monsieur
macron premier d'ailleurs qui après ce
bilan quand il se prend un retour à la
figure mais ça fait ça des gens sur des
bateaux sur la mer des gens sur les
bateaux sur la mère après on va les
chercher et c'est enfin bon il ya plein
il ya plein de et puis bon il ya un
moment où
il faut qu'il faut quand même se poser
des questions madame merkel nous a pas
nous a pas interrogés avant de faire
rentrer 2 millions de personnes chez
elles d'accord sauf que sauf que après
il rentre chez nous d'accord donc
l'espace
schengen ça fait que après il circule et
perso et madame merkel nous ne nous a
pas demandé l'autorisation avant donc il
ya un vrai il ya un vrai sujet là dessus
sur la migration dans le gilet jaune
c'est aussi un sujet qu'on pourra
aborder et donc le leu leu je pense
qu'il est en train de faire de faire
fixer l'attention là dessus parce que de
l'autre côté ils sont en train de
préparer à mon avis la sortie de l'euro
je peux moi je pense que c'est ça je
pense que alors je peux me tromper mais
je pense que dans l'idée c'est ça et et
comme d'habitude malheureusement nous
qui n'avons rien préparé parce qu'on ne
peut même pas en discuter c'est ce que
disait jacques tout à l'heure on ne peut
pas en discuter toute façon dès que vous
dites que vous êtes contre l'euro vous
êtes un nazi ça limite un peu le
l'expression
mais donc cet
idiot mais sa limite l'expression est
donc ça permet de ne pas débattre là si
l'italie sort en effet dans les semaines
et dans les mois qui suivront il y aura
éclatement de la ddt si vous n'avez rien
préparé là
vous allez vous retrouver à poil ça va
aller très vite c'est à dire qu'on va
subir bien plus que des gens qui y ont
réfléchi qui s'y sont préparées et c'est
donc dans
une en plus dans un contexte qui va être
extrêmement dur à cause de la récession
et je pense que ça on oublie aujourd'hui
parce que tout le monde est là fori
qu'en début d'année en se disant oui
allez on fait table rase de ce qui s'est
passé en 2018 et puis 2019 ça ira mieux
comme à chaque fois le seul problème
c'est que on va voir on risque d'avoir
une succession de choses qui vont
arriver en 2019 dans un contexte global
ce sera assez catastrophique avec rien
pour se rattraper donc si on a des
banques qui commence ça parce que
récession ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que vous allez avoir de plus en plus de
créances irrécouvrables on a déjà de 360
milliards en italie mais il ya sur les
360 milliards il y avait 220 milliards
de créances vraiment à 0 mais là vous
allez passer de 220 à 360 et puis même a
probablement à plus quand il ya une
récession vous avez de plus en plus
d'entreprises qui ne peuvent pas qu'ils
ne peuvent pas payer vous allez avoir la
même chose aux états unis aux états unis
qu'est ce qui s'est passé au moment où
le pétrole est repassé de 28 dollar à 80
dollars par les les sociétés pétrole de
schiste qu'est ce qu'elles ont fait
elles sont allées voir le banquier en
leur disant reprêter nous de l'argent
parce qu'il attendrait 1,28 dans l'autre
sens non de 28 à 80 quand on est
remontés ces sociétés qui étaient
complètement étranglé à ce moment là
sont allées sont allés revoir leurs
banquiers en leur disant refaite nous
une rallonge parce que il faut qu'on
sorte du pétrole maintenant résultat on
a fait 80 81 40 aujourd'hui elle repère
de l'argent d'accord et elle repère de
l'argent et si jamais vous avez le
le si jamais les marchés jouent la
récession vous allez voir que le pétrole
descendre à 25 il descendra 25 pour la
bonne et simple raison que les marchés
je parle pas de 2,2 de l'utilisation
mais là aujourd'hui
quand les marchés jouent une récession
ils jouent une contraction de la demande
ils se foutent complètement de savoir
s'il ya un moment l'arabie saoudite va
fermer un petit peu le robinet ou un peu
un peu plus gros le robinet et c'est un
tout ça c'est des cds projection à
beaucoup plus long terme ils vont pas se
dire non plus oui mais comme le pétrole
a baissé bahia est moins
d'investissement donc ça va que ça va
contraindre l'offre et que c'est à c'est
pas ça a marché un marché c'est binaire
c'est les gens qui sont derrière les
tables de marché c'est pas des cerveaux
donc c'est des gens qui vont à un moment
dire ok on coupe on balance on bazarde
et à ce moment là vous allez avoir le
pétrole il est descendu à 28 dollars n'y
avait pas le moindre il n'y avait pas la
moindre baisse de la demande à ce moment
là d'accord il n'y avait pas la moindre
à ce moment-là excès d'offre etc on est
quand même descendu à 28 mois je vous le
dis si jamais les marchés jouent la
récession on descendra à 25 ça veut pas
dire qu'on y restera l'on descendra à 25
ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire pour
les pétroliers de schiste notamment qui
perdent énormément d'argent qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire ils vont aller voir
leurs banquiers en leur disant donc
qu'est ce qu'on fait et les banquiers
vont faire faillite à ce moment là parce
qu'ils ont bossé oui alors la question
du pétrole est effectivement extrêmement
symptomatique des désordres dans lequel
on est voilà
marché du pétrole donc normalement il
ya une demande pour l'énergie il ya une
offre pour l'énergie ben ça devrait
arriver à s'ajuster et on voit un que le
marché est devenu aujourd'hui un marché
entièrement spéculatifs pour une raison
assez simple c'est que des institutions
financiers alors que ce soit des banques
ou des quasi banques parce que il ya
très souvent des des sociétés
financières qui ne sont pas des banques
bon on d'acheter du pétrole comme
réserve de valeur et aujourd'hui elles
détiennent une grosse partie du pétrole
deuxièmement on est sur un marché dans
lequel il ya des très grosses compagnies
qui ont les reins assez solides pour
tenir le choc en cas de fluctuation
temporaire des prix du pétrole puis on a
des toutes petites compagnies en
particulier dans le cas du pétrole de
schiste et ses compagnies est
effectivement sont très largement
dépendante du crédit bancaire
aujourd'hui
une compagnie américaine qui
est au texas où dans le dakota et qui
sort de l'appel de l'huile de schiste et
du pétrole de schiste il faut savoir que
80 90 % de son capital a été emprunté
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a là un
effet de levier qui était extrêmement
fort et par ailleurs ces petites
compagnies n'ont pas le même point
critique le point zéro le point où elle
commence à faire du profit que des
grandes compagnies quand vous avez une
grandes compagnies comme bp qui exploite
du pétrole de schiste parce que bp a les
moyens technologiques
bp
gagne encore de l'argent avec un prix du
pétrole à 40 dollars le baril une
petite compagnie en moyenne c'est plutôt
60 65 dollars le baril et il ya
certaines des petites compagnies qui
sont plutôt autour de 80 dollars le
baril
donc ça veut dire qu'on va être dans une
situation où effectivement si on assiste
à une faillite parce que les prix sont
trop faibles de toutes ces petites
compagnies bien ça aura un effet de
retour sur les bancs mais ça aura aussi
un effet dits de deuxième tour parce
qu'à ce moment là se posera la question
de ces fameuses réserves de pétrole sous
les aujourd'hui vous avez dans toute une
série de porc ou de grandes baies des
pétroliers qui sont à l'encré et qui ne
servent que de moyens de stockage de
l'huile ces
pétroliers ou le pétrole que contient
ses pétroliers c'est en fait de réserve
à des sociétés financières mais ces
réserves ont déjà été gagé pour
permettre à ces sociétés financières
d'emprunter or si
le prix du pétrole s'effondre à nouveau
les
prêteurs de ces compagnies financières
on leur dira d'accord mais votre
collatéral il a perdu tant pour cent de
sa valeur
faites la longue durée
ce temps qu'il faut pour votre
collatéral ce qu'on appelle c'est la
question des briques et des appels de
marges céder les prêts que les
collatéralisée et là de très nombreuses
sociétés financières ne pourront pas le
faire donc on peut avoir effectivement
un mécanisme qui démarre en fait parce
que l'on peut avoir soit un effet de
marché soit un petit effet lié tout
simplement un effet offre demande mais
qui peut provoquer ce jeu du marché et
qui peut provoquer par la suite une
espèce de détonations générale sur le
marché du vêtement givi biologie oui
moi j'aimerais réagir sur un ballack et
son départ comme j'ai pas perdus pas
perdu le fil en repassant par l'euro en
essayant de faire un lien entre les deux
on a beaucoup parlé tout à l'heure des
économistes je rebondissais est ce que
la plupart des économistes spécialistes
de la monnaie
depuis le début on expliquer que l'euro
marcherait un jeu très probablement pas
que c'était voire une très dangereux
j'étais
assez surpris quand j'ai enquêté sur sa
de voir que en tout cas un des plus
fervents opposants à l'euro était un
milton friedman alors qui est pas mon
maître à penser mais qui était
spécialiste de la monnaie et en qui en
l'espèce avait vu assez juste est ce que
pour ceux que ça intéresse j'avais sorti
sont son analyse sur mon site et
quelques années c'est très intéressant
de la relier aujourd'hui parce que vous
avez un économiste qui était politique
tout aussi bien qu'ils voient bien qu'il
ya un problème politique au bout d'un
moment et qu'ils aient fait pas ça vous
allez le feu déjà je comprends
pas pourquoi vous collez
le franc aux marques parce que c'est le
frein est beaucoup trop cher vous faites
du mal là faut arrêter d'être l'euro ce
sera pire m'enfin bon heureusement je
pense quand même y aura des gens sérieux
qui va pas se faire c'était ce qu'il
disait donc on va dire voilà un extrême
néolibérale maurice allais qui était un
autre prix nobel d'économie pendant
notre unique pendant très longtemps qui
est une espèce de libéral socialiste
disait très européiste et me disais ok
il faut faire ça mais d'abord faisait
sur tout homogénéiser on vous fait rien
tant que c'est pas homogène après
effectivement on fera des trucs
politique donc l'euro moi je crois pas
trop fait le reste avant et puis
maintenant vous avez même du stiglitz du
groupe man sur la pâtisserie qui vous
explique que ça marche pas pourquoi ça
marche pas parce que c'est ce qu'il faut
c'est il faut comprendre à monnet c'est
pas juste le truc sympa que lequel on
paye et coup sur lequel on a un peu
embêté quand on veut payer en allemagne
en pologne parce que là il faut changer
avance compliqué un bâtiment la monnaie
c'est le sens d'une économie c'est
extrêmement centrale et en particulier
sa sert a ajusté les économies entre
elles quand elles n'ont pas parce
qu'elles n'ont pas les mêmes
productivité quand le nouveau franc a
été créée dans les années 60 était
pratiquement un franc égal à marcq caen
années 90 on se met vraiment à figer on
est à trois francs pour un marc problème
de l'inflation si le promu du taux
d'inflation d'accord bien sûr ça ne peut
expliquer mais en attendant il y avait
un truc un pour un et puis c'est passé
quand même à 3 pour 1 en 25 ans donc on
voit que ça ces économies sont
différentes donc si je les
je les encourage les enserre l'une avec
l'autre il va se passer des choses
discuter ça peut se résoudre on peut pas
se résoudre mais il se passe quelque
chose c'est pas juste sans conséquence
donc ce que déjà ça ne marchait pas la
même façon donc quand vous arrivez vous
dit bah tiens on va faire une monnaie
unique est assez aussi intelligent
première métaphore que de dire bâtir on
s'aime bien ici tous les trois mois
je fais du 44,3 du 43e chaussures toit
du 40 ont fait une petite mine à 40 2
donc on va faire on va prendre les mêmes
chaussures parce qu'on s'aime bien mais
évidemment au bas de la même pointure 42
pour tout le monde c'est sa monnaie
unique c'est la même monnaie pour tout
le monde et qu'est ce qui se passe dans
cet exemple tout bête mais c'est que
quand vous êtes l'allemagne avec votre
40 bombes à votre 42 un peu grande en
soit ça va bien hein quand vous faites
votre 42e 2042 et ça fait un peu mal tu
es la france puis quand vous êtes à
l'italie ou la grèce vote 44 a fait très
très mal des chaussures 42 c'est
exactement ça qu'on fait parce que votre
monnaie n'est pas adapté donc comme un
et ça c'est un certain temps à penser en
fait aussi des indes et politique
l'allemagne est plus productif que la
france pour des raisons historiques pour
des raisons culturelles pour des raisons
de construction de son économie elle a
toujours été comme le japon beaucoup
plus exportateurs beaucoup plus efficace
sur ce point là alors on a des points
plus positif en france eux ils ont ce
point là en terme d'économie quand vous
mettez la même monnaie dans la zone vous
avez la zone alma d'allemagne qui plus
efficace donc effectivement petit à
petit ils commencent à pomper les
emplois les et celle plus compétitive
que ce qui se passe en france ou en
italie comme tu es plus le taux de
change qui avant faisait basculer parce
que plus l'allemagne et efficace plus le
marché monte plus le marque était cher
plus la machine outil en marque quand
vous êtes en italie l'été cher donc au
bout d'un moment qui s'est trop cher
vous achetez plus la machine-outil
allemande donc vous rééquilibrer
naturellement par la monnaie
sans comment dire son pilotage
centralisé les économies vous n'avez
plus à donc en fait l'allemagne pompe
les emplois et c'est ce qui se passe est
de plus en plus d'emplois en allemagne
et moins en moins de chômage n'avait
plus en plus dans la périphérie de la
zone cette étape là elle est tout à fait
logique et naturelle quand vous faites
une monnaie unique dans la zone rémy
remettant dans un pays qu'est ce qui se
passe mais se passe exactement la même
chose en france vous avez liste de
france qui a pompé les talents qui
pompent les cadres qui pompent large aux
deux plein d'argent en ile de france et
c'est là où on arrive à l'étape suivante
étape qui est beaucoup plus intéressante
en
disant deux choses premièrement pourquoi
ils ont fait ça ils ont fait ça passera
en bonne partie il avait essayé de
stabiliser les monnaies que c'était
monétaire européen pendant une vingtaine
d'années jusqu'au début des années 90 où
la financiarisation des économies ayant
augmenté les masses disponible est en
plus grande vous avez eu des
spéculateurs qui se sont mis à attaquer
les états les monnaies des états et
l'été 92 vous avez une crise où le
système monétaire en gros est à deux
doigts d'exploser en tout cas ne remplit
plus son son rôle de stabilisateur des
monnaies donc ça ne marche plus donc là
vous avez un problème ils ont un
problème en disant on n'arrive plus à
stabiliser les monnaies et donc là il y
avait deux voies possibles il y avait
une voie relativement logique qui était
de dire on va limiter la spéculation
tiers
que c'est plus open bars etc on va
simplement par exemple quand on va voir
quelqu'un qui va dire bonjour je
voudrais un milliard de dollars dans
notre banque centrale ben oui lui dire
vous les donne et que gary spéculer
contre notre propre monnaie bien que tu
vas en enfer view réponse
à ces pour acheter une filiale aux états
unis pas très bien on te donne
effectivement temps milliard de dollars
puis qu'on va vous dire bah non c'est
juste pour spéculer contre le dollar
puis après contre l'euro valait bien
désolé ça pète possible bonne journée
l'équipe n'ont pas fait ça et
passionnant je voulais pas s'attaquer à
la spéculation
plus je pensais aussi une idéologie de
laisser-faire de pas réglementés ne pas
dire non c'est pouvoir de dire oui si
les politiques ils ont dû battre at
année il ya un problème les monnaies bah
on va en faire qu'une mais sauf que
quand vous faites ça il ya des
conséquences et les conséquences je
reviens si vous avez des divergences
dans la zone et donc vous avez la zone
allemagne et qui devient extrêmement
productive efficace des zones italie en
grèce qu'il devient extrêmement pas
alors je j'aimerais venir c'est un peu
long mais ça répond directement la
question départ et c'est là où se pose
la question de est ce qu'on a fait un
pays dans la zone la question c'est
maintenant qu'on a ça qu'est ce qu'on
fait dans un pays puisqu'ils si on veut
faire notre pays européens bah c'est pas
compliqué on prend de l'argent en
allemagne on donne à l'italie on le
donnait la grèce et c'est ce qui se fait
et on prend l'argent d'île de france
pourra l'aider la lozère la corrèze pour
faire des routes en corse on est un pays
quand il ya plein de jeunes espagnols
qui vont travailler en allemagne parce
que l'emploi et là on vous dira pas
regardé une efficacité du marché du
travail ok ok question importante qui va
payer les retraites des espagnols les
jeunes sont partis tout à fait logique
de dire ben faut prendre de l'argent du
jeune espagnol qui travaillent en
allemagne pour payer arts table de
l'espagnol c'est ça un pays et là on
voit très bien qu'à ce moment là ça ne
marche pas parce qu'évidemment les
allemands ne veulent pas cette
solidarité la soirée dans une phase on
ne veut même plus payer des impôts pour
des gens de son propre pays c'est
sûrement pas pour aller en donner plus à
des pays étrangers dont plus une
propagande va dire qu'ils sont fainéants
regardez c'est pas paris on est
différent donc c'est sûr que le grec il
a cinquante raison critique et
l'allemand avec la demoiselle à 50
raison de critiquer le grec c'est des
cultures et des populations différentes
et quand on est spectateur demander
pourquoi on fait pas un seul pays bas on
pourrait faire un seul pays on peut tout
faire mais on peut faire à ce pays sur
la planète aussi en théorie et marchent
très bien vrai c'est à quelques
conséquences plus ou moins agréables et
la conséquence centrale c'est les impôts
et c'est le transfert budgétaire et on
voit très bien que mais je veux pas dire
d'égoïsme dit williams ne sont pas de
oui c'est tellement c'est normal ce sont
un travail en allemagne ne t'a pas
forcément envie de donner tout en argent
aux italiens pour les aider à sauver
leurs banques sa santé valais le faire
vos mails donner aux africains qui
meurent de faim si on va sûrement là
dedans en terme de solidarité je fais
donc la question la question centrale
elle est là elle est la solidarité c'est
pour ça que c'est compliqué parce qu'il
ya pas de peuple il n'y a pas deux il
n'y a pas la même culture tu es un grec
c'est pas un norvégien s'est pas un
irlandais c'est pas un estonien et
vous poser c'est la conclusion et c'est
la conclusion à la 2e minute excuse moi
un tunnel tu veux je
suis dit est ce qu a dit jacques
évidemment qu'on peut faire et que la
france après tout ça s'est fait comme ça
il y avait plein de trucs différentes
mais quand vous construisez entre
guillemets parce que c'est pas ça
s'apprend des siècles et c'est surtout
violent et non démocratique et non parce
qu'un jour il faut aller dire au type
qui parle la langue d'oil qui peut plus
parler langdon qu'il faut
donc il faut qu'ils parlent anglais donc
c'est ce qu'il faut faire en france et
si on veut faire un seul pays enfin en
europe ben vous dit à tout le monde
parralèlement bon puis ce sera beaucoup
plus efficace faut dire bah votre code
pénal vos cultures françaises vous
oubliez ça va être l'allemagne etc etc
alors à vous trois je vous pose une
question une histoire de vous lancer
bien loin
quel parti politique vous
voyez pour gérer ce qui est en train de
se passer le
moins celui
qui je alors je lance aux livide a
marché tout de suite aucun aucun
le le le on va on va on va redire la
même chose que la même chose quand en
que monsieur albert einstein il disait
on peut pas résoudre un problème avec
avec la même pensée qui l'a créée donc
là
aujourd'hui quel que soit le parti
politique c'est des gens qui depuis
trente ans ont créé ces problèmes donc
je vois pas aujourd'hui quelqu'un dans
les partis politiques traditionnels
quels qu'ils soient tous
d'ailleurs issus de la même école les
énarques
qui se prennent pour des élites qui
qui est capable aujourd'hui de de porter
un nouveau projet et de réfléchir
autrement et c'est ça fait ça fait des
années qu'il ya une espèce d'alternance
en fait entre des gens qui pensent la
même chose donc je
pense que déjà on
ne pourra pas faire
l'économie de de sortir déjà
l'union européenne de sortir de l'euro
et ensuite changer
les cadres d'une façon ou d'une autre
alors soit on fait quelque chose à la
suisse la suisse qui est-ce qui connaît
le ministre des finances suisse
personnes qui s qui connaît même le
président suisse personne qui est ce que
parce que ces gens-là change tous les
deux ans aider c'est vraiment des
administratifs et que c'est peuple
suisse qui décide pour lui donc
soit on atteint
ce niveau de
démocratie parce que c'est le seul pays
à peu près démocratique en europe donc
soit on atteint ce niveau là mais
là aujourd'hui dans le la proposition
qu'on a actuellement je vois personne
serait
un assez d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
olivier je ne vois pas aujourd'hui un
parti tel qu'il est capable
de gérer une situation de décomposition
extrêmement importante que ce soit sur
l'euro que ce soit sur l'économie
d'ailleurs globalement sur l'union
européenne ce maintenant il faut aussi
comprendre que la décomposition la crise
grave engendre c'est propre dynamique
politique et que donc soit on verra une
reconfiguration des
partis politiques une parenthèse est ce
que les gilet jaune sont mécanisme que
l'électorat de trump non c'est quelque
chose d'assez différent parce que
l'électorat de trump il faut toujours se
souvenir de ça d'abord c'est un
électorat qui est assez composite il y à
un bloc ultra conservateur qui
avait régulièrement voté pour les
républicains qui d'ailleurs c'était par
moments abstenu parce qu'il considérait
que le candidat républicain n'était pas
assez conservateur pour lui bon et puis
ce bloc a été rejoint par
des déçus des démocrates et par ailleurs
il ya eu un troisième phénomène c'est
qu'une partie des démocrates déçus tout
simplement ne sont pas allés voter et
vous le voyez par exemple quand on dit
ah oui mais l'électorat de trump est
raciste alors vous voyez qu'il ya une
partie assez significative des
noirs ce qu'on appelle les afro
américains ou aux états unis qui ont
voté trump donc voila c'était
un petit peu ça sur la question des
gilet jaune sous les villes et jaune
aujourd'hui sont
aussi divers que les le peuple français
vous allez trouver parmi eux des gens
qui votent pour le rassemblement
national comme vous allez trouver des
gens qui votent pour la france insoumise
et peut-être même des gens qui ont voté
ou qui votent encore pour mâcon qui
seraient prêts à revoter pour macron
bien par contre la dynamique de ce
mouvement veille il faut pas simplement
raisonner en termes de statique il faut
se dire qu'elle est la dynamique que ce
mouvement est en train d' impliquer dans
le système politique français dans la
société française et cette dynamique
elle est en réalité explosif pour
l'ensemble des partis constitués donc je
pense que on aura des recompositions
assez importantes qui se poseront et qui
ceux qui se verront à partir du moment
où il sera évident que l'on est face à
une crise majeure que ce soit une crise
économique que ce soit une crise de
l'union européenne que ce soit une crise
de l'euro
que pour l'instant - personnes ont
peut-être que olivier a plus de lumière
et dessus mais ce mois je suis
absolument incapable de dire c'est
qu'elles seront les formes spécifiques
que prendront ces recompositions moi
pour l'instant je ne les vois pas ce que
les gens vont réclamer un kaiser comme
dans toute crise l'a vu dans l'histoire
a nécessairement pas nécessairement
alors
on a déjà une option qui est out c'est
celle du fameux recours
l'homme
qui serait au l'homme ou la femme qui
serait en réserve de la république l'ama
parlant des candidats oui
bon d'accord sérieusement il y en a
aucun sérieux oui oui on sait c'est
hollande c'est hollande bon c'est
probablement la meilleure plaisanterie
qu'il ait jamais fait de sa vie en
réalité j'ai plein d'autres en réalité
on voit bien que ça peut être
effectivement une femme ou un homme
politique qui se dissout d'un coup et
qui disent aux français j'ai fait fausse
route en vous indiquant telle et telle
position et là je comprends qu'il faut
opérer un changement radical ça peut
être ça comme ça peut être quelqu'un
qu'on n'a pas vu venir et il faut pas
non plus négliger le fait qu'il y a dans
les différents partis qui existent
aujourd'hui en france des jeunes qui
sont des jeunes plus ou moins talentueux
il n'y a pas simplement que des petits
technocrates des gens qui sortent de
l'ena il peut y avoir aussi des jeunes
talentueux je ne pense pas que la
question de l'âge soit un problème
rédhibitoire même si c'est un problème
important parce que malgré tout il
faudra avoir un minimum d'expérience
pour gérer une situation est très
complet bloquer un adolescent voilà
c'est soit ça sera compliqué bien mais
n'oublions pas les généraux de napoléon
il avait qu un il avait 28 ans 1 l'aîné
les murs ah bon donc y'a yassa
fondamentalement
n'oublie grand charles napoléon voilà
alors le problème et c'est aussi je vous
ai dit cette recomposition va se
produire mais
il n'est pas impossible qu'elles se
produisent trop lentement et là le
problème se posera parce que si la
recomposition met du temps à se produire
si le mécanisme de recomposition est en
retard par rapport aux mécanismes de la
crise alors
la désintégration du pouvoir politique
deviendra-t-elle que l'on sera dans la
situation classique le pouvoir n'est pas
à prendre il est à ramasser et là d'une
certaine manière n'importe qui pourrait
effectivement se dire j'ai ma chance je
la tente et c'est pour cela qu'il est
extrêmement important d'être très
vigilants sur les procédures
démocratiques et pour réinjecter
justement le maximum de démocratie dans
les procédures existantes et c'est pour
ça que la question du référendum que ce
soit le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne où que ce soit le référendum
classique tel qu'il était pratiqué dans
la vème république sont aujourd'hui des
môles de stabilité en réalité dans notre
système politique parce que ce sont les
seules manières disons sont les manières
principal de réintégrer le maximum de
démocratie possible dans les procédures
il ya malgré tout deux autres
possibilités qui doivent être utilisés
conjointement la
proportionnelle alors on dit oui la
proportionnelle ça ne fonctionne pas
mais si en allemagne la proportionnelle
fonctionne en italie la proportionnelle
fonctionne cessons de dire que ça ne
fonctionne pas pu dire sur ça fonctionne
sous certaines conditions il faut 50 ans
on peut aussi considérer que le parti
qui arrive avec le plus de voix à une
prime de 50 députés d'accord mais la
proportionnelle il faut le dire ça
fonctionne donc ça c'est un point et moi
je dis merci à peu près partout dans
tous les pays et appelle tout à part
l'angleterre interrogé l'elysée pour une
fois mais il a succédé il ya un truc
intéressant genesee ça on le fait
généralement
et puis le dernier point ça serait
d'établir un système qui avait existé
avant à la fin du système soviétique au
début de la russie post soviétique
le système dit du vote contre tous si
les électeurs considèrent que le choix
que l'offre politique qui leur est
soumise et insatisfaisante ils ont
malgré tout la possibilité de prendre un
vol un bulletin qui s'appelle contre
tous en russe par la texture et quand ce
bulletin avait fait plus de 50% des
suffrages exprimés on refaisait
l'élection sans les candidats de la
première élection
ouais ça commence fort de ce truc là
c'est ça me semble très des partis
politiques sera très compliqué non
soyons sérieux moi
je pense qu'on en sort pour la
démocratie parce que je pense que c'est
un très bon système il faut vraiment
qu'on les seuils en france suspens et
pas un épiphénomène d'une hyper
consommation énergétique qui ça ne
restera pas dans l'histoire comme
d'épiphénomène de quoi la démocratie
c'est pas c'est pas à la démocratie je
travaille ça n'est pas encore on n'a pas
essayé moi j'aurais juste qu'on essaye
pour la mettre en place parce que ça
donne si ça tient un peu les suisses
pour le moment ça a l'air de pas trop
mal marché et on peut faire des choses
peut être encore plus adapté à notre à
notre notre culture moi
[Musique]
ce qui me frappe mais
ça c'est entre du maquereau nice qui est
assez keita c'est je
pense qu'il intéressera beaucoup de
personnes nous coûte chercheurs à
l'avenir un sétois un moment on te parle
de postes vérité des choses comme ça
c'est cette capacité très orwélienne à
mettre le mot contraire à la réalité
aujourd'hui
le discours de macron c'est de dire je
suis là pour protéger les institutions
de la république face aux extrémistes
mot populisme un truc bon bien sûr la
république en connaissent et de gaulle
qui les a fait c'est à une crise tu
faire l'affairé d'hommes pour demander
si tu restes et puis si t'as pas 50% tu
t'en vas c'est ça les assises sur la
cinquième bon comme il à 20% de soutien
et je pense qu'il veut pas trop le faire
c'est
de dire oui mais je suis le symbole de
la démocratie face au populisme mais
déjà je répète ça quand à 20% de soutien
s'est tu t'en vas normalement tu restes
pas quant à 80 % des gens qui demandent
de romette relief turow milliers cesse
en fait on n'a pas demandé ton avis
c'etait pas d'accord c'est pas grave
n'est pas là pour voir un avis c'est ça
la démocratie c'est le peuple qui décide
parfois que se trompe mais parfois c'est
pat morris truc mais ça me semble
préférable d'avoir le peuple qu'ils se
trompent après un débat démocratique que
d'avoir des types comme macro qui
décident pour nous parce que résultat
c'est pas terrible terrible pour le plus
génial d'entre nous il ya deux ans
a contrario face à ce discours de je
suis la démocratie bla bla bla enfin il
ya des événements gravissimes dans le
pays et on en est à 100 blessés graves
dans les manifestations dont 15 du sein
tout ça les blessés de 2000 blessés
graves non non il ya 100 blessés graves
est pas de blessés mais dd c'est grave
libération on tient compte assez
intéressant sans blessé grave la 15
types qui ont perdu 15 types et femmes
qui ont perdu un oeil et c'est quand
même pas mal c'est ça c'est ça se passe
au venezuela héros ça vraiment on en
parle beaucoup mais chez nous il ya un
temps d'antenne qui est négligeable sur
ces trucs là on travaille un peu bidon
et maintenant les médias ont pris on
sent blessé grave ont alors manifesté en
france à enfants à l'internet où
l'information circule mais une maman de
sites en plus sûr de plus en plus coût
énorme et ça crée une violence contre
les médias qui est dangereuse c'est
évidemment les gens qui voient ce qui se
passe et puis qu'ils voient ce cas sur
bfm les
trois quarts qu'ils réfléchissent un peu
sa fierté après qu'une forme de violence
dangereuse et contre contre contre les
journalistes quand immédiat depuis
seulement sept pauvres journalistes sur
le terrain qui qui finit par s'en
prendre non parce que la violence allait
tels que bah voilà qu un trop plein et
en face ce pouvoir est de plus en plus
aux abois on apprend que la maintenant
la semaine dernière par première fois
ils ont fait sortir des fusils
mitrailleurs enfin il ya un niveau de
violence depuis trois ans a été sentie
plus longtemps mais non mais là il ya eu
tout un peuple ont commandé qui a été
fait pour les sortir la dernière fois
vous
avez dans une forme a plus un moment
donné dans un discours de l'afo faire
attention démocratie libérale il est en
train de nous en montrer une démocratie
libérale manquons
pas très bien qu'ils s'enferment là
dedans qui n'a absolument pas partie
pour vous de quoi que ce soit qui a un
mois il est venu comme un pénitent nous
dire excusez moi c'est vrai que j'ai
peut-être choquer certaines personnes
pardon pardon puis et qu'une rechute
façon un gilles de la tourette là sur un
bataille import salle au salon auto
fainéants faire waouh c'est c'est
impressionnant sur sa capacité à gérer
les symboles enfin en même temps notre
exemple puisqu'il parle des pauvres qui
sont pas cohérents enfin et comme carlos
ghosn est toujours président de renault
je pense qu'on a le premier président ça
fait deux mois qu'il est en taule quand
même hein c'est bien débuté avec un
bracelet électronique ah oui non mais là
le gars y est quand même sur un tatami à
trois boules de riz par jour au japon
mais on l'a laissée à la tête de renault
en disant attention il faut quand même
préserver l'alliance renault nissan
c'était discours ce que j'ai entendu en
plus c'est des trucs complotistes c'est
la faute à nissan mais en tout cas que
vraiment l'alliance renault nissan
c'était important rappel la base c'est
comme nissan qui porte plainte contre
son président qu'il agirait donc déjà en
termes de relation avec nice m c'est
très intéressant c'est à dire il ya une
gestion de ce truc là je développe pas
plus ce qui est phénoménal et qui
montrent que l'équipe ils sont
incapables de gérer des trucs
élémentaire donc la forme ses formes de
violence monte et ozzy mais on en sort
comment et ça me semble très difficile
parce que dans les idées elles sont
intéressantes mais on est dans une
monarchie élective et il n'y a pas
d'institution pour corriger ça il ya un
mode de scrutin qui est extrêmement non
démocratique est en voie de mettre la
gentille faudrait dissoudre des
dissoudre mais enfin j'ai entendu parler
d'études qui montrent que s'il ya une
dissolution c'est encore un public en
marche qui gagne avec leurs 20 % de
soutien parce que ils auront très
souvent le front national contre en
marche ou la régal républicains contre
en marche et que dans le système là les
mexicaines toujours des députés alors
que bedimo système proportionnel déjà
serait une façon de rééquilibrer chose
d'avoir de nouveau partie d'un des
recompositions pudiquement la pâle
système proportionnel et des types ils
vont pas voter un système sachant que
c'est exactement ça leur faire perdre le
pouvoir
donc ce truc là face à un pouvoir qui
n'écoutent pas qu'ils fassent à des
violences à être moins inquiétante le
pays bascule et là vous avez un exécutif
qui vous dit un jour faut qu'on soit
plus radicaux dire
qu'il se prend après un lens palette la
fin de journée le gars est vous avez
lendemain premier ministre qui vous dit
on va aller encore plus loin avec nos 20
% de soutien parce qu'on est démocrate
talât orwell va vraiment je pense qu'il
fait des pirouettes l'attend c'est quand
même impressionnant et donc comment on
sort de ça c'est très compliqué les
solutions et bah j'en sais rien un petit
bonhomme bien si un bâtiment on n'a pas
mis la démocratie en place depuis un
moment si on se mobilise pas moi je
pense que ça va monter en pression on
peut encore faire par avoir des morts et
là c'est comment ils réagissent face à
des morts et jeudi moore oui nous menons
maintenant on va dire des enfin qu'un
jour on va avoir un flic qui tire flash
ball et que le gars est mort l'a déjà le
pompier volontaire qui est dans le coma
à bordeaux ça commence à créer un petit
peu mais ils étaient mortes directement
induit par les actions de répression et
filmer un de tes films et maintenant
c'est une grande différence avec mai 68
bien sûr mais toi malik oussékine ça
fait parce que nous avons tout ça mais
aujourd'hui ça se passerait quand on les
voit il se passerait rien je pense que
tahar ben oui mais le gars c'était
surtout un boxeur et les morts va tant
pis continuons et ça peut durer très
longtemps ce truc là en plus à se
demander s'ils sont juste bête ce qui me
semble généralement mon hypothèse
favorable aussi font exprès de pourrir
la situation c'est pas possible de ne
pas en sortir de ne rien proposer et
donc ce truc là ça peut durer sont en
train de faire des magouilles avec l air
pour essayer peut-être de faire un
gouvernement d'union nationale d'un
public en marche les républicains waouh
super je prends ça va calmer les choses
assez rapidement peut-être pour aller
encore plus loin ils ont conclu radicaux
chez les 3 l air qui reste donc re
décomposer mais le problème c'est qu'on
va voir un bloc central et puis on va
voir deux extrêmes et les deux extrêmes
a comme je ne parle pas il risque de
rester au pouvoir longtemps et dans une
cocotte-minute qui finit par exploser on
aura pas d'alliance on aura pas d'avion
selon vous comme ce qui s'est passé en
italie avec mais déjà un g3 pas de ces
les fantasmes et 3 je rappelle que en
italie de la petite différence est
qu'ils ont environ un peu plus de
démocratie là bas l'acacia
proportionnelle et bien il se passe des
choses ne se passera rien terme et
auront fait des élections tas de nouveau
la république en marche qui quasi
automatiquement le poser
la question de savoir s'il y avait un
parti qui mais si tu change pas
fondamentalement le process ça change
rien tu as toute une administration
derrière les politiques cdc des
communicants cd porte parole y lisent un
texte que d'aidés aux fonctionnaires
leur écrivent et que des hauts
fonctionnaires et aussi les gens qui ont
financé pour qu'il soit élu donc
si tu changes pas à ce système la fête
qui qui qui est derrière macron depuis
le départ c'est une marionnette macron
il ya il ya un certain nombre de grands
capitaines de l'industrie dont on
va pas citer les noms on les connaît ras
le bonjour draghi et c'est donc xavier
niel je vais pas faire la liste carlos
ghosn psy mais jamais sur d'autres types
ces gens là on comprend pas d'ailleurs
on demande à notre communauté ne pas
oublier de duty pee wee pas pour la
libération de carlos ghosn qu'on soit
bien donc je fais mais d'en parler et
donc le
tout ces gens là ont été derrière
l'élection de de macron le regretté
michel berger qui est mort heureusement
derrière mais pierre bergé pardon qui
qui heureusement
pas ses larmes à gauche mais donc ça le
sait c'est des gens qui ont directement
financé macron donc si si on change
simplement d' équipe on va mettre deux
ou trois partis qui vont s'allier ça ça
va être la même chose je vous parlera la
même en fait il y aura la même
corruption parce que c'est c'est de la
corruption depuis le début on est là on
est un des pays souvent rompus au monde
dans le système politique est le plus
corrompu au monde donc qu'est ce que
vous voulez faire vous allez changer
vous allez changer l'étiquette mais
c'est le même pot de beci parce que vous
avez déjà discuté avec ses grands
capitaines d'industrie je vais vous
prendre un exemple j'avais
eu une discussion très intéressante avec
un monsieur qui s'appelait henry hermand
qui était le mentor de d'emmanuel macron
et le monsieur me disais c'est
lui ou sinon c'est la bim en termes de
guerre économique la france est dans une
merde tellement noir que on va se faire
manger par tout le monde en
termes de renseignement s'est fait
ouvrir dans tous les sens par les états
unis la chine donc ils ont accès à tous
nos secrets de business
les russes non c'est toujours les russes
pourquoi non merci et donc un
lien la dernière fois à oui c'est vrai
c'est l'italien seppi qui tombèrent
germans et donc ils poussaient macron
d'ailleurs trois ans avant qu'il soit
élu en
disant c'est lui parce qu'après on est
foutu mais c'est pas un argument c'est
comme l'euro s'il n'y a pas d'euro on
est foutu mais c'est pas un argument ça
veut dire quoi on peut faire ça avec ma
porte je te prends je te prends à la
mûre rien dans la rue jeudi 6 et si
c'est pas lui c'est sûr que c'est la fin
du monde ça veut rien dire c'est
simplement que il poussait derrière
parce que c'était leur poulain ils ont
décrété que c'était un poulain et qu'il
allait défendre leurs intérêts qu'ils
allaient défendre leurs intérêts mais on
voit qu'il est même pas capable de
défendre quoi que ce soit
aujourd'hui quand même rires mais il met
y aura les mêmes entend communicants ils
ajoutent pas s'il te plaît jacques alors
je pense que traiter comme ça c'est
faire trop bon marché de
la marge d'autonomie libanais
indépendance de la marge d'autonomie cas
le président de la république et cas le
pouvoir je
ne crois pas à une détermination
immédiate et directe de
ce pouvoir par les intérêts économiques
il je dirais plus de ce point de vue là
l'influencent de la technostructure
bruxelloise
mais bien sûr que macron à et place dans
les normes et loki en france tous
azimuts choses différentes bien sûr que
macron a été soutenue financés par ces
grands ratés ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
n'est pas lui même une certaine marge
d'autonomie maintenant quant à la
technostructure française pour la voir
un petit peu fréquentées dans différents
ministères je peux dire que le haut
fonctionnaire français a deux
caractéristiques 1
il est lâche 2
il
sert le pouvoir quel que soit le pouvoir
ça n'engage que vous non je dis je
reprends
40 rui regardez ce qui s'est passé sous
vichy regardez ce qui s'est passé sous
vichy et donc je pense qua non mais tous
les tous les hauts fonctionnaires
regardez les patrons regardez les
bousquet certains de ses hauts
fonctionnaires il a été bien sûr
certains de ses hauts fonctionnaires
était même considéré comme des radicaux
socialistes avant
la seconde guerre mondiale il faut faire
très attention à ça et donc je pense que
quand bien même arriverez un
gouvernement souverainiste en france il
pourrait compter sur le soutien d'une
grande partie de la haute fonction
publique
le véritable problème c'est que macron
incarne aussi ce qu'on appelait le
dégagisme semer qu'ils s'en aillent tous
qui a été popularisé par jean luc
mélenchon il
a aussi incarné macron et il faut voir
qu'aujourd'hui c'est
à dire ce qui lui a permis de compter de
construire une façade acceptable à ce
bloc bourgeois en montrant un visage qui
en juin 2017 n'apparaissait pas encore
ouvertement comme trop réactionnaire ce
que la mobilisation des gilets jaunes a
changé c'est le fait que le côté ultra
réactionnaire
de ce bloc bourgeois est devenu tout
d'un coup évident il a perdu tous
ses atours justement de bah oui un peu
réactionnaire mais d'un autre côté il
veut faire des choses qui sont bien qui
se peuvent être intéressantes tout ça ça
a disparu et aujourd'hui on voit très
bien que emmanuel macron et son pouvoir
sont
réduits à leur plus simple expression
politique c'est à dire ce qu'on appelle
le camp de l'ordre et le camp de l'ordre
strictes autrement dit cette incapacité
à tuer
puis surtout à faire émerger des
solutions qui peuvent mordre sur une
partie de l'opposition qui pourrait
reconstituer un
ym homme de consensus veut dire que
celui
qui est devenu de fait le dernier garant
du camp de l'ordre est un facteur de
chaos de plus en plus important dans les
institutions françaises et de ce point
de vue là il n'est pas impossible que
les gens qui l'ont soutenu l'abandonnent
sauf que là ça sera un pari terriblement
risqué qu'ils prendront parce que dans
l'état actuel de la situation il n'y a
pas d'alternative qui soit crédible
instantanément
alors on peut dire que donner l'heure
entre 12 et 18 mois peut-être
arriveront-ils à redonner
un coup de ripolin au rassemblement
national et en faire un parti qui
pourrait être un peu plus présentable de
leur point de vue pas aujourd'hui est
donc ce
qui va se passer dans les semaines qui
viennent voir dans les deux trois mois
qui viennent sera extrêmement crucial
pour l'avenir de notre pays parce que et
là je rejoins tout à fait ce qui est dit
olivier si lors du prochain acte ou d'un
acte suivant on a des morts en
manifestation il faut rappeler que des
morts en manifestation il y en a eu très
peu en france depuis 1962 si on met de
côté la fameuse manifestation
de charonne et la manifestation des
algériens bon après on a eu très peu on
mai 68
gilles totain mais c'était dans un cas
très particulier c'était une
manifestation à flins et il est tombé où
il a été poussé dans la seine on a eu
deux ouvriers à sochaux qui ont été
soufflées par une grenade et qui ont été
tués parce qu'ils sont tombés en arrière
on a eu un commissaire de police qui a
été tué mais ce sont
dans les conditions de l'époque c'était
extrêmement faible aujourd'hui
compte tenu des armes dont dispose la
police du
lanceur de balles de défense en
particulier le lanceur de balles de
défense à coups multiples bons les
grenades il est tout à fait possible que
l'on est dans les 15 ou les trois
semaines qui viennent que l'on ait des
morts en manifestation même
si les médias chercheront à étouffer
cela on peut penser que grâce aux
téléphones portables il y aura très
rapidement une diffusion très large de
cette nouvelle et à ce moment là le
pouvoir sera effectivement à nu des
têtes au bout des piques je
n'irai pas jusque là mais je dis que le
pouvoir sera à nu il faudra prendre des
décisions qui seront des décisions
d'urgence et
à ce moment-là peut-être que la solution
la moins mauvaise pour la paix civile
sera une des missions des manuels macron
parce que il a concentré aujourd'hui sur
son nom et sur sa personne une telle
haine qu'à un moment donné même si on
peut considérer que cette haine n'est
pas entièrement justifié et je pense que
cette haine est un petit peu excessive
elle peut être comprise par un
souterrain mais elle est aussi un petit
peu excessif néanmoins cette n existe
c'est aujourd'hui un fait et à un moment
donné il
faudra qu'il en tienne compte et qu'il
en prenne sa part d'une certaine heure
et qu'il démissionne s'il n'est pas
capable de faire cela là les événements
pourraient être extrêmement grave où il
vit maintenant mais même derrière ta les
soutiens au talent système qui va finir
par dire oui
ls peut réagir c'est interdit mais quand
même tu vas voir pouvoir médiatique où
une classe aristocratique et qui va lui
dire bon junior l'intelligente y tu vois
ça peut être possible faut partir s'en
va mais se passe quoi on a une
présidentielle où il ya le pen wauquiez
aise castaner et mélenchon et de ça va
sortir un des quatre et la paix civile
va venir avec un de ces quatre personnes
que ce soit ça peut être un moment une
trêve dans la crise tout ce que je pense
que la crise sociale va durer je pense
que la crise sociale est très profonde
en france et qu'elle va durer mais si on
reprend alors je sais que jean luc
mélenchon adore jouer à ce petit jeu
mais si l'on reprend l'historique de la
révolution française sap a été le 14
juillet tous les jours ça pas été tous
les jours les
femmes parisiennes allant à versailles
pour comme on disait aller chercher le
boulanger la boulangère et le petit
mitron il ya eu des moments où la
situation redevenait un petit peu calme
donc on pourrait repasser par ce type de
calme et là se posera toujours la
question est ce que on est capable de
faire émerger et quand je dis on nous
aussi les opposants est ce qu'on est
capable de faire émerger une solution
qui soit politiquement viable
à la fois en termes programmatique et en
termes de soutien dans l'électorat ou
bien est-ce que l'on revient à cet
affrontement entre un bloc réactionnaire
assez réduit et un bloc certes multiples
fractures et mais un bloc largement
majoritaire qui veut le départ de ce
bloc réactionnaire et à ce moment là on
repartira dans l'affrontement olivier
delamarche les
fondamentaux de soutenabilité sociétale
comme par exemple la finance comment on
va la finance en ce moment tout va bien
pour
le moment tout va bien on est on est on
a une petite alerte en fin de fin
d'année et
puis on
est remonté enfin jeudi à yahia il n'y a
rien de nouveau sous le soleil pour
l'instant c'est c'est maîtrisé personne
ne s'occupe du fait que les banques ont
perdu 90% de leur valeur comment trouves
ça normal personne se dit qu'il ya
peut-être une raison fondamentale
là-dedans enfin mort que tout va bien
parce que parce que les gens sont
toujours dans cette danse est petit de
dire ok les banques centrales sont moins
sont moins marquée de friendly mais ceci
dit dans chaque allocution les banquiers
centraux répète à loisir que même s'ils
sont un petit peu plus un petit peu plus
dur de toute façon ne vous inquiétez pas
parce que si jamais il ya quelque chose
qui se passe on sera là et on fera
tourner la planche à billets donc il
se passe rien mais il se passe rien
j am on
s'en fout un peu enfin le le
cac40 faut un peu dépassé ça c'est pas
aujourd'hui c'est pas le sujet
même si certains croient encore que
c'est la queue qui remue le chien est
projeté remue la queue si tu veux il se
passe quand même des choses en
économiquement et
socialement et politiquement qui sont
autrement plus graves que de savoir si
le cac 40 va baisser de 15% par an on
s'en fout un peu leleu
je t'ai dit je pense que en étant d'ores
et déjà en récession et que ça va ça va
progresser
là dans les mois qui viennent une
récession ça vaut 30 40 % sur un marché
c'est le sait le sait le prix habituel
donc on va reculer à un moment ou un
autre de 30 40 % qu'est ce qui va se
passer à ce moment là bas ce qui va se
passer ce qui s'est passé à chaque fois
puisque toute façon aujourd'hui les
banques centrales n'ont plus les moyens
de d'intervenir c'est à dire que l'étau
ils sont déjà à zéro on
a déjà inondé le monde de billes et donc
elles feront exactement la même chose
puisque aujourd'hui en plus elles sont
fondamentalement dépendante des marchés
financiers dépendante pour tout d'abord
parce qu'elles ont acheté des actions ce
qu'elle n'avait pas à faire elles ont
acheté des de tf6 qu'elle n'avait pas
non plus à faire c'était pas leur boulot
et donc qu'elles sont passées de
d'institutions qui avant était ce qu'on
appelle date indépendante c'est-à-dire
qu'elle dépend des des chiffres
économiques des tendances économiques à
des institutions qui sont devenus
totalement market dépendance
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui elles en ont
tellement dans leur bilan ce que c'est
les grosses sicav c'est les gros et fun
et qu'elles ne peuvent pas se permettre
un repli important sur des actions et
sur des hobbies donc puisque une banque
centrale qui fait entre guillemets
faillite ça fait désordre quoi c'est pas
ça dans les dents les dans les logiciels
donc elles peuvent pas se le permettre
elles peuvent pas se le permettre parce
que aussi tout le système est basé
dessus aujourd'hui tu as des fonds de
pension qui sont à peu près tous en
déficit et puis en déficit pas un peu en
déficit jusqu'à 60% et c'est donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que c'est
ces institutions là comme aussi
certaines institutions françaises ont
mis du risque parce qu'il fallait quand
même essayer de récupérer un petit
quelque chose donc elles ont mis du
risque dans leurs portefeuilles pour
certains le risque c'est quoi ces les
actions c'est ce qui marcher jusqu'à
maintenant pour essayer de récupérer un
petit peu d'argent et donc qu'elles ont
mis du risque sauf que quand il ya une
récession le risque ça paye pas trop
donc si aujourd'hui tu as des fonds de
pension qui sont déjà en déficit de 40
50 60 % imagine ce que ça va donner le
jour où les marchés vont reculer de 40
parce que l on on plaint dans leurs
portefeuilles d'actions et est donc
aujourd'hui on peut se dire que dans ce
cas là comme ça comme le monde entier
dépend de sa et tous les systèmes
dépendent de sa la retraite des
fonctionnaires américains le bon tous
ces systèmes là fonctionne là dessus
qu'est ce qui va se passer il va se
passer que les banques centrales vont
intervenir et elles l'ont dit à ce
moment là comment
on peut imaginer les choses tout
simplement aujourd'hui
rien n'est marqué ils ont un excellent
laboratoire pour ça c'est le japon ils
sont aperçus qu'en fait le japon depuis
la des mois et même deux ou trois ans
achète tout marchés actions les au tf
les oublie tout et
son sont le niveau de bilan de sa banque
centrale dépasse aujourd'hui le pib
japonais et donc donc en fait qu'est-ce
qui empêche les états unis de faire
pareil rien d'ailleurs que si demain le
banc le le patron de la fed dit moi je
mets deux mille milliards pour soutenir
les marchés être à deux mille milliards
et il se dit toute façon il se passera
rien puisqu'il se passe rien au japon la
monnaie reste au même niveau et donc
qu'il se passe rien il est tenté de se
dire y'a rien de graver dans le marbre
qui disent qu'une banque centrale doit
avoir tant 2% dans son actif de 2 du pib
si on sort dans la rue et comprend 15
personnes et qu'on leur dit demain le
bilan de la banque centrale européenne
qui est 4700 milliards il passe à 6700
milliards je pense pas que tuer des cris
d'orfraie de deux de ces gens là donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire tout
simplement que ils mettront le paquet
sauf que là où ça risque d'être un petit
peu différent de la dernière fois c'est
à dire des premiers quantitative easing
c'est qu'on sait aujourd'hui très bien
que ça n'a aucun impact positif sur
l'économie aucun sait on a payé pour
voir ça ne relance pas l'inflation c'est
déflationniste à la relance il une
chaise dans leur classe voilà et ça et
ça ne relance pas l'économie en rien bon
et donc le le problème aujourd'hui c'est
que qu'est ce qui va se passer quand les
gens vont comprendre que ya pas de
sortie possible il n'y a pas de plan b
c'est à dire qu'à partir de ce moment là
ça veut dire que la banque centrale est
condamné à vitam aeternam à soutenir les
marchés puisque dès qu'elle va se
retirer ça va retomber et c'est moi à
mon avis là qu'on risque d'avoir un vrai
problème c'est à dire une fuite devant
l'amener c'est à dire la monnaie qui
s'écroule pourquoi parce que les gens
vont piger que c'est terminé il n'y a
pas d'autre possibilité que continuer
à fuel et ses marchés parce que dès
qu'on va arrêter les marchés vont se
casser la gueule et donc alors tu auras
une période où très probablement les
marchés remonteront parce qu'il y aura
quelques gérants un peu demeuré qui
vendirent chouette on nous donne de
l'argent gratuit pour aller jouer sur
les marchés on va y aller et puis enfin
la banque centrale s'est remise derrière
nous donc on a pas de raison d'aller
contre un on va on va aller avec elle
les marchés vont monter dans ce cas là
assez assez fortement mais moi c'est la
phase d'après qui m'inquiète c'est la
phrase c'est la phase où les jeux les
aider les investisseurs un peu smart pas
les idiots mais les investisseurs un peu
smart pour se dire ah et quand même un
souci c'est on n'a pas de plan b on n'a
pas de plan de sortie et si on a plein
de plans de sortie ça veut dire que on
est condamnés que le bilan il va être de
2 50% du pib puis ensuite de 62 70 de 82
90 200 de santis et on le voit au japon
très bien depuis des mois monsieur qu
roda nous fait le coup à peu près tous
les trimestres de nous dire oh on va
tenter le coup de baisser un petit peu
nos achats et d'arrêter les quantitative
easing et à chaque fois à chaque fois
les taux les taux d'intérêt à 10 ans
japonais repasse au dessus de zéro et
puis là on voit des lendemains monsieur
que roda qui arrive à la télé qui dit
pas pop up vous met mal compris je
recommence parce qu'il peut pas se
permettre quand on a une dette qui fait
260 ou 210 % du pib on ne peut pas se
permettre d'avoir des taux qui prennent
un point parce que ça fait 2,7 de plus à
payer dans ce cas là olivier envie
de rebondir non un
petit tunnel non jacques je
suis d'accord je suis je suis assez
d'accord avec ce qu'a dit olivier
simplement
je ne sais pas quelle forme prendra
cette défiance est ce que ça peut
relancer un mouvement d'inflation s'il
n'y a pas de mouvements de très forte
inflation je ne vois pas les les ménages
privés sur les le ménage de base dire
j'abandonne la monnaie tant qu'il n'y a
pas de forte inflation les ménages
conserveront la confiance dans
l'instrument monétaire
le vrai problème c'est effectivement
cette accumulation de liquidités et de
liquidités de plus en plus spéculatives
et je pense que ce qu'on verra c'est la
formation et l'éclatement de bulles
spéculatives de plus en plus rapides et
sur des domaines de plus en plus
éloignés des domaines habituel bon
on a parlé du pétrole mais on pourrait
avoir des bulles spéculatives qui se
forme sur les autres matières premières
sur les céréales en particulier on a
déjà été pas loin de ce type de
situation en 2008 2009 et ça ça peut
avoir des conséquences tout à fait
dramatique pour toute une série de pays
c'est parce qu'ils ont des jipes tu vois
là on peut avoir évidemment des bulles
spéculatives qui se reforment sur
l'immobilier bon état et je pense que on
va être pris dans une situation où des
bulles apparaîtront éclateront en
quelques mois dans des secteurs qui
seront de plus en plus je dirais
étonnant pour
nous et ça ça peut effectivement in
fine et déstabiliser profondément alors
là je suis d'accord c'est mais les
ménages ils vont être déstabilisé très
vite 6 si c'est ça qui se passe pour la
bonne et simple raison que les banques
se retrouvent parce qu'aujourd'hui tous
les modèles de risque font que tout ce
qui n'est pas habituel n'arrive jamais
on est dans la loi de gauss a donc tout
ce qui est un petit peu en dehors ça
n'arrive jamais seule expérience ça
arrive malheureusement ça fait mal et
donc si on a ces éclatements de bulles
aucune banque ne tiendra si on a des
banques qui sautent qu'est ce qui va se
passer ça veut dire bel hymne et
compagnie donc là le
le particulier va s'apercevoir très vite
que ça a pas bien est ce qu'on va lui
prendre son argent donc ça va ça va vite
le ou alors on aura une nationalisation
de certaines banques avec
de l'argent emprunté à la prêts auprès
des banques centrales oui non mais ça
fait toujours le même la même chose
c'est-à-dire qu'on fonctionne toujours
sur les sur cette planche à billets avec
une espèce de fuite en avant qui fait
qu'on en crée toujours plus en moi je
veux bien que les particuliers soit soit
un peu aveugle mais enfin il ya un
moment où je pense qu'ils vont
comprendre que à force d'en créer il ça
vaut plus grand chose et on arrive à la
fin de notre notre interview la question
qui n'est pas une question s'est laissé
une bouteille à la mer un conseil pour
les jeunes générations et je rajouterais
laisser un conseil pour les gilet jaune
en plus du conseil pour les jeunes
générations une
bouteille à la mer pour les jeunes
générations
virez
revenait à cannes non pas aux gens qui
disent s'inspirer de kane revenait à
keynes n'écoutez
pas les
hommes politiques quand ils se mêlent
d'économies un conseil pour les gilets
jaunes votre
véritable bien sûr que votre ennemi
immédiat il est à l'elysée
c'est le bloc conservateur et
réactionnaire français
mais ce bloc il ne peut exister dans sa
forme actuelle que parce que il s'appuie
sur l'union européenne votre véritable
ennemi il est à bruxelles c'est l'euro
c'est l'union européenne nous
libérons hui pour
les jeunes générations gm a informé vous
déjà sur cette interview
et pas que enfin que non mais pas que il
faut aussi dire les médias mainstream
faut aussi lire le monde il faut aussi
80%
des infos y sont mais il faut juste
savoir les lire certains germes en page
24 il faut faire un petit corrélation
avec qu'est ce qui s'est dit dans le
figaro aussi page 12 c'est ce genre de
petites enquêtes qu'il faut faire et pas
de complot nous cache rien enfin tout
cas en bonne partie mais il faut
certainement diversifier ses sources
d'information débattre discuter et puis
penser librement voilà savoir se
remettre en question savoir argumenter
contre argumenter parfois s'amuser dans
un débat à défendre la position opposée
à celle qu'on pense vraiment je ne
pouvais rien dire tiens comment je
défendrai ça c'est comme ça quand on a
une vraie liberté liberté d'esprit et
puis vous mettez pas de limites parce
qu'il ya plein de choses à reconstruire
parce que on est en fin de cycle cadre
d'un cycle depuis la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale mon avis
accentuée par la mondialisation et la
financiarisation des années 90 et c'est
ce truc là qui est en train de faire
naufrage de se prendre le mur de la
réalité donc en effet vraiment falloir
réinventer beaucoup de choses avec des
gens sérieux et surtout des gens moi
ce qui me frappe aujourd'hui c'est le
manque d'éthique de la plupart des gens
qui sont qui sont là tu sais c'est
vraiment une forme d architecture morale
qui a disparu et
il m'épate parce que c'est un c'est
vraiment pas évident d'avoir des gens
comme ça qui sont capables non pas de
mentir un peu enfin bon je me rappelle
de jacques chirac dans les années 90
soit plus par la compagnie guignols
supermenteur m'attendais mais était
sérieux chirac bien sûr qu'il juge veut
réduire la fracture sociale ma chatte
mais ce n'était pas un type qui vous dis
aujourd'hui mais c'est en plein été là
il fait 35 degrés aujourd'hui la
canicule ces gens sont capables de faire
ça aujourd'hui puis fois deux mois
contre l'effet que news ils ont une
capacité en tout cas dans dans la tête
d'une partie de ses séides qui sont au
pouvoir actuellement donc de ne plus
avoir d' acheter à turbo et et quand
j'en vois certains moi je je je les
comprends pas parce que moi je me
suiciderai dont tu t'es président de la
république le type était plus de maîtres
comme des barrières autour de chez lui
qu'un hélicoptère près à l'extrader
enfin oui il ya un problème la wii
m'expliquerai l'extrader l'elysée dans
un premier temps on te fait après ça
deviendra dans un deuxième temps ça donc
oui ça s'est retrouvé retrouvé une
architecture morale qui disparaît
vraiment ça se joue à aurillac quelque
chose de ma de se tenir à un certain
nombre de valeurs pour les jets les
jeunes vous a déjà parlé mais je dirais
voilà continuez à vous battre pour le
rite parce que c'est pas la panacée mais
c'est quelque chose d'intéressant pour
mettre la démocratie en place et par
rapport à ce que tu disais pour essayer
de lutter contre l'un des maux qui nous
frappe qui est important ça se passe de
bruxelles isme un qui fait que ça vous a
piqué la démocratie les amis il faut se
réveiller et vous voyez de plus en plus
qu'on vous l'appliquez semaine après
semaine avec de plus en plus de 1 de
recul démocratique soit forces de
l'ordre dont on a beaucoup parlé on peut
toujours dire oui non mais les types ils
sont un peu dans l'urgence est compliqué
mais des magistrats il se passe des
trucs au niveau de la justice qui vient
aussi le bras armé du pouvoir pour
expliquer aux gens que va pas manifestés
sinon déjà qui va taper de garde à vue
parce que tu appelles des lunettes et un
foulard à rabat yatim un examen ou
21 des condamnés à un an ou deux ans de
prison dans des conditions qui sont
quand même quand même discutable donc et
se battre pour se battre pour ce à quoi
oublier pour
les jeunes d'hier est ce ça va rejoindre
mes deux petits camarades ayez l'esprit
critique
ne prenez pas pour argent comptant ce
qu'on vous raconte pas ce qu'on vous
raconte quand même beaucoup de bêtises
donc
ayez l'esprit critique et essayer
de essayer
d'avoir de la du bon sens parce que je
pense que c'est ce dont on manque le
plus dans cette dans cette période et
alors ce dont tu sont totalement dénuées
nono nos dirigeants mais simplement du
bon sens parce que c'est finalement
c'est pas très compliqué l'économie
c'est des additions de soustraction de
trois divisions enfin c'est à la portée
de n'importe quel étudiant mais ces
gens qui font l'ena sont totalement
dénuée de bon sens et le bon sens ccc
d'appeler un chat achat de deux de voir
que il ya des impasses
dans lesquelles on se précipite tête
baissée et c'est tard le le le j'aime
beaucoup le le l'image de la chaussure
de pointures mais ça c'est du pur bon
sens et ça ne sais pas on comprend très
bien que ça peut pas fonctionner avec 3
mo et une image qui peut paraître au
premier abord un
peu simpliste mais c'est ça on explique
comme ça très bien le le montage delà de
cette simili
monnaie et donc voilà
si si on avait un petit peu plus de mon
sens chez nos dirigeants je pense que ça
ira beaucoup mieux après sur les gilet
jaune je vais leur dire
courez vite et mettez un gilet
pare-balles en ce budget les jaunes ça
peut ça peut servir parce qu'en ce
moment c'est quand même du tir au pigeon
qu'on fait j'ai l'impression donc voilà
donc et puis ne vous bourrez pas de vous
courez pas de combat c'est à dire on est
en train aussi de faire des fixettes
sur l' isf sur b mais c'est pas ça le
vrai combat vrai combat c'est c'est
enfin d'avoir un système démocratique
qu'on
n'a pas eu depuis depuis belle lurette
et puis ces
deux de sortir de cette de cette
immobilisation qui est créé par par
l'europe par pas par l'union européenne
et par et par l'euro donc se
réapproprier son pays son économie son
son
tous face à souveraineté et donc et
le pouvoir donc de prendre des décisions
donc c'est pis elle parce que je pense
que c'est un petit peu ce que cherche
aussi d'ailleurs le le pouvoir c'est c22
probablement avec le grand débat c'est
de les orienter sur des trucs annexes
qui en fait n'ont aucun intérêt d'accord
et qui vont les diviser ils vont
s'écharper sur le fait de s que tu veux
remettre line et s'est fait ce que tu
veut baisser tel ou tel truc est ce que
tu veux mais en fait si
on décide et demain de 2,2
d'augmenter le smic etc au
final au final on ne peut rien faire
puisque toute façon l'europe va nous
tomber dessus on nous dira lé déficit
budgétaire et que ça donc le
vrai problème le vrai sujet c'est est ce
que vous voulez diriger par notre
alcooliques anonymes ou est ce que vous
voulez pas être dirigée par luis est ce
que vous voulez retrouver des dirigeants
chez vous que vous élisez ou pas
dirigeants et un système à la suisse sur
lequel vous décidez pas cheap anonyme
qu'on peut pas virer et c'est avec
grand plaisir que tu parlais justement
de délai ne tue pas et des hauts
fonctionnaires tout à l'heure et c'est
intéressant en effet est un des
mécanismes de l'ena ça consiste à
essayer de sélectionner des gens qui en
grosse partie vous rentrez dans ce que
disait jacques donc autrement dit avoir
des gens qui soient pas forcément très
enfin qu'il soit lâche et qu'ils soient
prêts à servir le pouvoir quel qu'il
soit est un des mécanismes de sélection
de l'ena c'est pas forcément d'avoir mec
le plus cultivé le plus intelligent
quelque peu de bon sens ça ça soit plus
soumis faut avoir le type faudra voir le
type qui est prêt à faire tirer sur les
villes est jeune c'est ça l'ena c'est
préfet si le préfet bout d'un moment on
va falloir faire tirer sur les mineurs
et à 50 ans mais j'ai les jeunes
aujourd'hui donc c'est un mécanisme
qu'on sélectionne donc c'est pas
étonnant qu'il soit comme ça seulement
le message aux jeunes ce sera justement
non non non non c'est soyez courageux et
ne servait pas n'importe qui ne savaient
que les gens qui méritent et c'est comme
ça que mon avis et vous aurez une
intégrité morale d'antenne fierté aussi
ou raser le matin messieurs merci pour
ce long entretien on tenait à passer un
mot gilet jaune blessés on a une chaîne
russe pensée pour eux
on pense vraiment a voulu et fit bonne
soirée
[Musique]